[Music]
hey
hello and welcome to the break room a
special d23
saturday edition we're all in our grays
and
overcast tones
but don't let that fool you we are very
excited to be here this is new rock
stars live show streaming uh directly
from our headquarters here in los
angeles from our actual break room uh we
are reporting today on d23 that is
happening right now down in anaheim um i
think as we speak the cast of andorra is
on stage
i'm here i'm i'm my pleasure to be here
with erica woo john costa tom michaelson
uh too fast for the lower third sorry
about that
my broadcast skills are lacking uh and
i'm zach huddleston we're all excited to
be here um
we have some people on the ground in
anaheim we've got tommy bechdel brandon
barrack and the eric vos are down there
physically in person watching these
panels they're going to be uh reporting
back to us both during the panels if
they're allowed to sneak out their
phones and text us
but certainly after the panel's wrapped
they're going to be phoning in and
telling us what they saw obviously any
trailers footage that gets released to
the public while the panels are taking
place we're gonna show those react to
them lose our minds um anything that
gets tweeted out or reported while
things are going on we'll be reporting
on those live to you there's no place
you can stream this or watch this you
have to stare at our mugs um while we
drink from these mugs okay um
cheers uh cheers
you can uh buy these mugs at new
rockstarsmarts.com along with lots of
other great merch okay um but real quick
as we get hyped for it yeah the things
we're thinking we're gonna see today
right and again we know we're getting
kevin feige on stage talking marvel
hollywood reporter said it's gonna be
casting announcements there's gonna be
big news dropped and they said footage
now we don't know if that's gonna be
footage shown just to people inside the
building which you know again we'll have
people reporting on that stuff after the
panel all the exclusive footage but
i'm hoping we get yeah a little bit of
footage for us at star wars celebration
they did show some mandalorian footage
uh that is yet to be released to the
publix there might be some stuff that
they show that they don't release but
again we'll have brandon and tommy to
report on that um we also know uh it's
already started we're getting lucasfilm
announcements absolutely and in between
we're getting 20th century announcements
formerly known as fox probably be some
avatar news maybe some other big news
indiana jones five maybe alien news
maybe predator news we don't know um all
kinds of stuff could come out there
there's a lot of great franchises from
that studio as well all under the disney
umbrella um but real quick the biggest
things we're anticipating getting today
um
fantastic four yeah
casting and we already know the cast is
eric yes
and i am the thing i'll be ben griffin
i'll be sue story yeah i'll be uh yeah
i'll be johnny storm they're gonna try
again with the black johnny storm
it'll be much better than michael b for
sure i'll be greg storm
their uncle that does their taxes and
things like that
i'm in space somewhere
richards is a bowl of spaghetti right
now
the world's sauciest man
uh the rumors have been flying around
the internet about casting for that
right we don't have a director confirmed
again big speculation that matt shackman
director of wanda vision might be
announced there today um we were just
saying that at uh kevin feige's big
comic-con panel where we got two and a
half phases worth of films and disney
plus series laid out not so much casting
stuff not a lot of big casting news
didn't pull out that many unknown uh
previously unannounced actors or
directors or anything like that so maybe
they were saving that for this also
we know there are a handful of projects
that have been talked about that are as
of yet unslated right there's a lot of
gaps in those phase five and phase six
calendars we're hoping they're going to
fill in some of those if you watched the
break room last week we went through
some possibilities marvel like announces
to theaters hey we want you to earmark
this date for us um one of those is in
phase five i think it's sometime in
february 2024 people think maybe
deadpool 3. so there's a bunch of little
gaps in that game there's a lot of stuff
that they've already announced like
world by night and things that aren't
we're on the calendar at all so we're
expecting that to be filled in here and
there as we go too right people in the
chat are pointing out and the android
crews on stage right now they just
showed the final trailer for andor
uh that show's coming out on september
21st yeah weeks away wednesday uh
week away from that
that's of course the next disney plus
series that's going to be coming out uh
we might we might play that trailer in a
little bit um and again we're
anticipating other lucasfilm
announcements including
when's the next movie coming out what is
the next movie who is the next movie why
is the next movie
where is gamora i mean uh in the you
know so many directors and you know have
been attached to various star wars films
that are kind of like eternally delayed
as they shift their focus to
disney plus series but at some point
they're going to go back to theaters
right we were saying yesterday that like
it seems like a lot of studios are like
okay we might have overdone the
streaming stuff it's time to yeah it's
time to get butts and scenes
what's interesting is that lucasfilm
actually
at one point every time they announced
the movie it was like a trilogy like
right they were like here's the ryan
johnson maybe trilogy happening which
might not be and then the guy from the
guys from game of thrones are doing a
trilogy too here's that coming out it'll
be interesting to see if it's going to
be a one-off thing if they're not a
movie it's going to be a trilogy because
taika for example we know that's coming
but that's one movie i think right
one way or the other taiko ytt has the
busiest item to be
that guy is attached to like 14
different films there's no way he can
make half of those but it would be
interesting if he comes out on stage
you know with kathleen kennedy
boy it seems like oh this one's his
first shirt next project yeah
and we are going to be showing that
indoor trailer in a second the the crew
from willow is on stage
while they go over shout out shout out
warwick we'll get that we got that
trailer up and running for you guys for
you come on the show warwick um
thank you to everybody real quick shout
out to everybody that's in the chat
being active uh we see a lot of like fun
ideas projections predictions getting
thrown out there also thank you to
everybody throwing us some super chats
we appreciate you uh giving us a couple
doubloons there helps us bring this show
to you gary porch abraham karina joelle
flipside everybody there
and and also if you have some great
questions some theories some predictions
some casting throw those into super
chats and we'll try to get to those as
the show goes along um cool so other
things we mentioned fantastic four we're
anticipating we mentioned star wars film
and or as of yet unannounced series of
casting i mean
we have yet to see
a drip drop of werewolf by night yep
which presumably would be coming out
they haven't announced it they haven't
even said it's real the only thing we
know no no is the director gave an
interview that was like yeah it seems
exciting
so i mean we've long been speculating
that's coming out this halloween season
but that is right around the corner for
them to wait anything about it now this
could drop as like an im groot style you
know maybe it's a short maybe it's
delayed till next october
uh maybe it was never meant to be we
don't know but we know for sure because
we've seen set photos uh guardians of
the galaxy holiday special yeah is
coming out this holiday season
maybe we'll get some footage from that
maybe we get first trailer or footage
from ant-man the wasp quantomania yeah
that's the next film after wakanda
forever
um then all the disney plus series
slated for next year we're getting
secret wars
we're very excited oh sorry secret
invasion we're also going to see rewards
secret invasion is the very next disney
plus series then echo um and then loki
season 2
iron heart in agatha house of harkness
all of those 2023 so maybe we get some
clips maybe we get some casting
announcements we don't know
um john are you pulling up the indoor
trailer yeah well andor trailer is
forthcoming but i figured we would you
know we could throw up some some
some of the slate that's upcoming yeah
so one thing that's interesting in that
list that we've we've talked about a lot
on this show and about new rockstars is
where's armor wars and all this i was
just thinking that that was announced
way back when and it's granted we as we
just said there's a lot of gaps in the
schedule but we've not heard any casting
we've not heard any directing don
cheadle is sitting at home yeah
twiddling his guns
waiting to go wearing the mocap suit
yeah boom looking for this yeah yeah
yeah he must have just broken into the
stream i accidentally triggered the
mandatory fun graphics
i'm sure he'll love that he felt it my
ipad days are numbered
again a couple people asking what we
think the order of these presentations
we know these three studios are going to
present their stuff we think they're
starting with lucasfilm 20th century is
going to be in the middle and the closer
marvel mr feige is going to be on stage
with the big stuff there at the end
that's what we're anticipating over the
next 90 minutes to two hours something
like that um so if you're if you're
sitting there waiting for marvel
announcements you will be waiting for a
little bit but that's okay we'll get to
it and if you're watching this after
we've gone live there's probably some
nice time stamps down there that john
has given you you can hop right to them
um
yeah so let's talk about lucasfilm a
little bit while they're still on stage
we we're getting willow right now what
do we think do we think we're gonna get
any any
footage from mandalorian season three i
say yes i think that's the next trailer
we're gonna get yeah um but then we've
got like ahsoka that's that's we know
that's still shoot that's shooting they
just announced the
uh actor who's playing ezra bridger um
so so we all know that's in progress do
you think we'll see any of that stuff i
think we'll see that so i was i was
lucky enough to go to star celebration
too and they had even though they had
only been filming for a few weeks they
had footage from ahsoka to show us and
it was really i don't know how they did
it they had like it would add trailer
music and of course no graphics or
anything but they also had some really
interesting teases like the crew from
rebels we had to see some twilight tales
from hera and some other things so i
think that now that it's been you know
celebration was what may so we we've had
a lot of time now they've got a lot more
footage in the in the bank they could be
showing us some ahsoka stuff today for
sure yeah um some people in the chat are
saying where do we watch d23
unfortunately you can't right here
right here
welcome uh uh we're gonna do our best to
bring you something worthwhile and what
and it's gonna be great instead of
scrolling through twitter like the rest
of us have to do um but yeah you're
right that wasn't that was in may um we
also have a season two of the bad batch
coming up that's right
that hasn't been talked about too much
that show was like a kind of a surprise
for me in terms of how good it was yeah
and season two i think it was supposed
to be out around now and got delayed if
i'm remembering correctly i don't
exactly know when season two is supposed
to come out but
what are you guys most excited for if
you had to pick one out of ahsoka
mandalorian season three and maybe one
of these either the taika movie or the
john watts skeleton crew movie oh i'm
i'm i'm i'm gonna say none of the above
and or
we can't skip past and or yeah they're
doing we were just talking about this
they're doing 24 episodes
of anador across two seasons they've
already committed to that i think
they've already i don't know if they've
already shot all 24 but like this is
like what a commitment like disney with
disney plus has not done anything more
than nine episodes right and they're
committing to 12 per season for two
seasons for this story like everything
that's coming out about this show is
like it's unlike anything else it's
gonna be like kind of super adult and
dark mature and like not a lot of
lunchbox characters coming out of this
thing you know what i mean do we know
how many um how many how long each
episode is are they 30 minutes are they
an hour
close to that hour long yeah wow i think
the first three episodes dropping
september 21st just uh you know a little
over a week from now we'll be covering
all of that on uh new rock stars eric
voss will be doing breakdowns wikileaks
will be doing after shows it's going to
be a good time um sounds like they're
they're debuting a willow trailer right
now yeah christian slater has joined the
cash
star wars knows that like their key
demographic is elder millennials and
boomers okay and they're like let's just
stack the deck yeah yeah um or not star
wars lucasfilm right willow of course uh
a lucasfilm production uh the classic
val kilmer warwick davis awesome swords
and sandals and sorcery uh flick from
now on i've never seen i've never seen
the original willow oh this might have
to be
it's worth a while watching it should we
cozy up with hank
play let's just roll with it roll the
whole movie right
willow right now
uh yeah um is that on dizzy plus oh
that's a good question i think i think
it might be could be yeah who knows
let us know in the chat if you see it on
disneyplus but yeah endor sounds really
fun i i am interested to see it because
it is a kind of a different direction to
go from you know pew pew and
yeah but i am excited for ahsoka because
she is jedi and like i want to see the
continuation of her story and her battle
against the mandalorian was so cool like
in that mandalorian uh season two
episode and yeah she she seems like a
phenomenal character uh and then humble
brag i have worked with rosario dawson
i played her jealous boyfriend in a
music video one time wow
okay there we go i'll send you the
picture
yeah no i'm super excited for so good i
love the jedi stuff and yeah and this is
like an opportunity to follow a non
skywalker family jedi and hopefully
non-tatooine i mean we all love we all
love that little we tie these hats yeah
but with that little planet that
supposedly is a great place to hide that
everybody goes to a nose and right i
don't hopefully add or doesn't go there
hopefully ahsoka doesn't and of course
like that character in the animated
series has like a rich lore and a lot of
like interesting story lines they could
explore they could also give us
something
different from that that we haven't seen
yeah news stories of course yeah um yeah
that that series looks like it's going
to be really good um and then again
anything unannounced like we don't know
we know a lot less farther in advance
star wars product than we do marvel
product right we've got our next
seven years of uh mcu mapped out ahead
of us roughly but like not a lot beyond
that ahsoka and middle orient and even
the patty jenkins uh rogue squadron
movie is that happening still is it not
how do you know about watching an indoor
trailer let's do it let's do that john
all right
[Music]
spies
saboteurs
assassins
we've all done terrible things on behalf
of the rebellion
cassian ander
don't matter what you tell me or tell
yourself
you'll ultimately die fighting these
bastards
wouldn't you rather give it all at once
to something real
we've chosen a side
we're fighting against the dark
there is an organized rebel effort drill
down and get a hunt started
you realize what you said
people will suffer
time has come to force their hand
at what cost
everything
every day we wait
they get stronger
let's take them by surprise
for the greater good call it what you
will
let's call it
star wars and or three episode premiere
streaming september 21st
you know what you know what i miss from
star wars a little bit is like the pure
rage that certain characters have yeah i
feel like we're gonna give that a little
bit yeah i mean
also not a lot of cgi characters in
there no banthas no uh
uh alien we don't have a lot of in
obi-wan either
right
but like no no baboo frick type
character no jar jar type character with
a big presence in there no no wookies
visible in that trailer droids no drones
a lot of droids now it could be those
things are going to be in the show
they're just not showing us in this
trailer also brandon barrick has pointed
out multiple times on the show that he
loves how stellan skarsgard says cassie
and ander
[Laughter]
lots is still in skarsgard in that
trailer just to keep everyone happy and
up to date dave felony is now on stage
uh and of course as soon as they start
talking about mandalorian season three
and andy we'll let you know
uh ooh i just want a trailer for
mandalorian season three more than
anything in the world that show this the
director they're going with that show
for season three is so exciting to me
din jaren looking to sort of redeem his
people and you know put mandalore back
on the map and it looks like we're going
to mandalore it looks like he's going to
be
which is kind of going to be crazy and
and all of that storyline is something
that like they just sort of started to
tease for the first time i mean every
scene with the armorer so good oh yeah
both the first two seasons are awesome
and it looks like she's going to be
heavily featured in season three right
like in similar characters we're gonna
get lots of man what if mandalorian
season three is just called mandalorians
oh like aliens yeah that'll be dope
another quick update it sounds like uh
filoni has just introduced um something
called tales of the jedi which are some
animated shorts those are gonna debut on
october 26th on disney plus and three of
those episodes three of them will be
about ahsoka i i think that was the show
i heard about they're also doing a count
dooku oh cool like pre one while he was
a jedi before he broke bad and became a
sith i think that's right about that
an animated one yeah i think that
they're gonna tell his story and talk
about his fault too one thing i was
gonna say about the andor trailer which
i didn't even think about till watching
it right now is
could we see the bad batch in andor this
is around that time tabuera morrison
could maybe be
be doing what uh quintuple duty yeah
how cool would that be because it's
around the same time right i mean i
don't know the exact they're probably a
few years off here and there but it's
it's right in between the empire and
revenge of the sith that's where all
this is happening you know what was kind
of interesting about that trailer not a
lot of diego luna in that trailer that's
right luna was in two shots of the first
trailer too using a hologram and then
one shot in a ship i don't understand he
is the titular character
was in this more than he was
so interesting to me i'm wondering if
they're doing these three episodes they
say the first three episodes of the show
are sort of their own contained story i
wonder if we're just not gonna get a lot
of diego luna in those three episodes
they're gonna tell a quick story that
sets up kind of players on the map
and then we get into the then we get
into the andor stuff interesting yeah
although i mean we did see uh if you if
you missed this on thursday disney
released on disney plus day something on
disney plus that was like uh it seemed
like uh skarsgard's character and andor
meeting for the first time there's a
little bit of a shootout in this
warehouse looking thing so if you're a
subscriber to disney plus you can check
that out on their website now but that
seems like a first episode kind of a
thing too so you know who knows what's
up tales of the jedi trailer just
dropped too okay so maybe we'll have
that that trailer that we can pull up
here momentarily um also a reminder and
this is just a public service
announcement if you're not a jezzy plus
subscriber hey what's up with you b
right now you can subscribe for a month
for 199.
that month will cover you'll be
basically be able to watch all of
she-hulk 411 thunder is streaming right
now
on disney plus and you'll be able to
catch at least a big chunk of amdor so
why not subscribe now or or like finally
stop using your mother-in-law's password
you know there's so many things on the
internet you subscribe to for way more
money yeah give some of that money to
some disney plus yes john favreau is out
on stage it seems like the beginning
okay we're about to get samantha news
it's the beginning of the ahsoka section
okay okay yeah so maybe we get some
footage that we could be able to play
for you john's working on filling up the
um uh tales of the jedi trailer yeah i
think you want to play that okay great
um i think we just got a super chat hour
and cones you think any stranger things
actors will be cast for marvel today
there's been a lot of talk about um i
forget his name but the actor plays
lucas being miles morales i've seen him
podcast as a milestone that would be
yeah
thumbnail oh many times for years yeah
he actually it's been so long that he's
been rumored he might have aged out of
miles right morales already watching the
last season of stranger things is like
this is the perfect time and this was
filmed like 10 years ago miles is uncle
right yeah
well uh what's the um
the the red-haired uh mercedes sadie
thinks he's used right now he's in a big
brendan fraser movie that just debuted
the whale at venice film festival that
people are saying like a that movie and
brendan fraser and her are all great
she's having casting like madame webb
has she i think she's one of the only
female actresses
hot in terms of popularity
no i don't think so i don't think she's
been in any superhero thing but she's on
the up and up so and i mean hey millie
bobby
she's out there she's working waiting
she's late oh millie bobby brown there
was a report this is just a few months
ago now that her and kathleen kennedy
had had a lot of conversations about her
starring in a in a movie for star wars
so who knows that might be announced
today too uh i forgot about that
you have to imagine if favre is already
on stage he's going to talk about ahsoka
and maybe into mandalorian
what's what's the closer for lucasfilm
what's the big mic drop moment at the
end of this panel
i think they roll out either john watts
or taiko ytt
and talk about their film it's gotta be
or judah coming out for skeleton crew
yeah something big like that or they
announce
a chewbacca movie
and that's our return to cinema
heartbreak feels good in a place like
this
joseph serrano in the chat says i'm
fancasting 11 as professor x similar
kind of uh power set yeah
brain powers
uh yeah is that the internet on fire
there uh joseph
um yeah great okay jen are we ready
can we roll training i'm not sure i've
got to get word from our man uh behind
the scenes okay we're still working on
it but uh we'll bring that to you as
soon as we're able um what i do have is
a new title card for ahsoka let me oh
pull that up nice
and then do we want to do maybe a quick
recap since yeah 30 minutes since we
started
yeah absolutely
um in fact we can go ahead and start
that as john works on this so again so
far we've only had the lucas film panel
is currently ongoing we know next we're
getting a 20th century panel and then
we're closing with a marvel panel uh
probably getting big announcements in
all three uh we saw a pretty cool andor
trailer that we've already played um
they announced a
tales of the jedi tales of the jedi uh
animated show a limited series animated
show which real quick what a nice thing
about disney plus right
for the first time in their kind of
history they no longer have to make if
they have content that doesn't make
sense for a theater or for a full season
or multiple season arc on a on a network
right like if you just want to do i am
groot and drop like five little mini
episodes or you just want to have like
three little mini episode animated um
things tales of the jedi setting up
ahsoka why not you get to drop them on
your service and
be fun for the fans yeah
great yeah
all right we got the trailer
ready to go reminder this is a six
episode shorts uh and and so that's
coming out october
everywhere there is life
but
you must face
death
honor it
do not fear it
jedi
ahsoka is jedi
the best way i can protect you
is to teach you how to protect yourself
master dooku i want to bring peace and
order to the galaxy
stop
it is the only way you will truly have
victory my opinion
again
again
stand down
[Music]
i'm tired of fighting
i've been warning them about the coming
darkness
let's hope all that training pays off
and who might you be
[Applause]
[Music]
tell us some of the incredible things
let me change my pants real quick yeah
that was pretty good keep them on my
dude
by brown powder
yeah
real fast before we recap that really
quickly i just want to let everyone know
uh john watts is on stage now talking
about skeleton crews here we go as the
news about that trickles in we'll keep
you posted but but tom
okay yeah a couple just
quick because i just saw this i like you
all for the first time a couple of
things that was uh young count dooku
with this blue saber so there is and and
two different unbearded and bearded
versions and masked versions of him
right that was someone else i thought
wow that's a new character that was a
double-edged new a lightsaber villain
um and when he said who might you be to
ahsoka i think that's what everyone else
is saying well who are you supposed to
be his mask looks similar to uh midnight
to the old republic there's a character
darth revan
i think yeah who has that but i think
that's obviously not him because it's
happening during the clone wars so this
show as we could see was happening right
in the middle of the clone wars
specifically early clone wars animated
show and attack of the clones era
because we saw anakin at the short hair
we saw there was younger ahsoka with the
green uh you know
mace windu alive mace windu and we saw
young qui-gon jinn
count dooku's padawan and that's what he
was talking to in there so there was so
much uh rex we saw rex in there there
was a lot of star wars in that trailer
if you didn't notice but but yeah those
are the some of the quick call outs that
i noticed people in the chat are saying
that that might be the sixth brother an
inquisitor oh
so also tom did notice as well the
trailer was playing yaddle yes yes
which is interesting that they bringing
her they're bringing her back because
the the grogu was supposed to be whoa
the the first of this species since yoda
went but really yaddle was on the jedi
council in the phantom menace never had
any lie yeah she just sat there so there
everyone has questions yeah maybe she's
the one who's going to be related to
brogue in some way new rectangles has
made a thumbnail that is uh yoda
f's
that little piece together it sort of
made me think that those people at
lucasfilm wanted to make another season
of clone wars but they had sort of
closed the book on that show and they
just wanted to kind of get everyone back
together and they were like you know
here's a place that we didn't get to
explore that much that we wish we could
have covered on that show so it feels
like maybe another spiritual successor
to that yeah and one thing really
interesting i saw is that they said from
the creators of the clone wars and the
bad batch but they did not say the did
not say rebels which is notoriously a
disney you know like disney was the one
who put the axe on the clone wars and
said we're gonna start this new animated
show and it's going to be rebels and
that show took a while to you know to
gain their game their fandom but it was
interesting to see that they didn't even
name drop that they were specifically
trying to tie it into the dave filoni
universe of star wars characters so
that's interesting they had felony out
on stage
this this clearly the guiding hand i
mean they squeezed a lot into that
little teaser and again this is a it's
not like a full season of a show
six shorts so i want to quickly pivot us
to skeleton crew let's do it right uh
john favreau was on stage and and this
is what he had to say about john pepper
or jonathan favreau was on stage this is
what he had to say about john watts he
said i've been lucky enough to be an
actor in the three latest spider-man
films this is john favreau he said when
i was working on them i was working a
lot with john watts who's the director
of the spider-man movies and he says and
i happened to mention to him that it was
super fun working on star wars and and
he was having a blast and favre told
watts that he should come out and direct
an episode of the mandalorian or
something like that you know we've seen
price dallas howard do an episode peyton
reed didn't episode
yeah yeah they kind of grabbed their
buddies to direct these shows and then
watts said
he responded that he had a fully fleshed
out idea of what that project was and
who should be who who it should be and
he said i don't want to do an episode
right i want to do my own project
so then they brought john watts out and
chris ford who maybe is one of the
writers or something to talk about
skeleton crew watt says it's an entirely
new story that we're excited to tell you
and then they showed this image dashiell
if we could pull that up
uh
jude law in some kind
that's perfect in costume but then yeah
some kids there in the background um so
no trailer we didn't get a trailer this
is the image that we got
interesting on the left of that little
orb coming out is the the door guard you
know like
the thing that comes out of the wall the
jabba's palace and also amanda lawrence
he's probably going into some shady
underground layer there this this show
and some of the casting has been
announced right that it is jude law and
some kids it's got like a goonies energy
or something like that
maybe this is where the stranger kids
things are showing up yeah
all of them the whole game
is successful yeah
and so now the mandalorian crew is on
stage so when we get news or a trailer
about that we'll bring that to you you
know i love to see uh properties do
crossovers so it's nice to see a cree uh
from
real quick shout out to kate silva
sending the super chat do not sleep on
tails before to tales of the jedi so the
first short at celebration it's next
level yes uh john saw that too and was
equally as jazzed um yeah that that was
a great little teaser we also got this
title treatment for skeleton crew that
looks very uh retro kind of you know
1980s
vhs cover kind of looking thing it's
also interesting i mean just from the
title and that image and what we know
about this series right doesn't it feel
like
um
jude law and a bunch of kids have to
man a warship fight a battle something
like that right skeleton crew in in you
know the parlance of our times means
like oh the regular people aren't here
we're running
yeah so you can see that being like
which again is like great to like
recapture the youth of
you know um those initial uh trilogy
films where all those actors are so
young
um yeah that looks like it's gonna be
really cool now uh one of the directors
for mandalorian season three rick
femigiwa is on stage right now if you're
familiar uh his great movie dope was so
much fun
uh he directed some episodes of the shy
um which is a cool show
he's on stage he's gonna do some
episodes of of mandalorian season three
here's what he had to say he said this
has been a dream of mine since i first
saw star wars which was the first film i
ever saw in the movie theater i think
that's true for a lot of us he says he
went to usc film school because of
george lucas and then he introduced the
cast of the mandalorian katie sakhoff is
there giancarlo esposito is there pedro
pascal everyone's doing a little reunion
little hug so
hopefully we get some footage of that
soon he's done some of the coolest
episodes of the mandalorian i think his
first episode was in season one when
they were when uh he's fighting the
mudhorn i think uh i think he he
directed that one i'm not sure if he
directed the prison break one but he's
done several i mean him and deborah chow
and john falwell they've all kind of
taken turns at bryce alice howard so
he's done some some of the cool i mean
they've all they're all great episodes
but he's done some of the really cool
ones also the usc film school army rolls
deep okay
coogler george lucas uh spielberg's in
that crew
um yeah yeah heavy hitters for sure i
gotta go and roll and get it right we're
gonna film we all have a lot of mistakes
kill my guidance counselor yeah i can
tell you right now uh there's a title
card up for the mandalorian and it is uh
as sort of standard as it has always
been so no no the mandalorian yes this
year you at home with your star wars
font emulator can make it yeah
yeah but well that's okay
um cool so you're not giving away a lot
we don't we don't have any footage yet
no footage no but i we do have this
title card courtesy of eric voss if we
want to throw that up hey it's just a
nice green color oh we got giancarlo is
that jane carlin the white coat in that
show i think so yeah yeah a bunch of
people yeah
yeah yeah i think the green mandalorian
might signify maybe a big return of
grogu maybe yeah comes in stronger more
in control of his jedi powers right i i
like uh us over reading into font colors
that's what new rock stars is all about
designer that's what i do
also also interesting pedro pascal
appears to have hinted that some
interesting guests are backstage uh
probably a little groggy animatronic
maybe
they brought him out for a celebration
him and they had a live-action
real-life chopper that was remote
controlled rolling around saying he's
the droid from rebels they're bringing
him back for the ahsoka series too so
that was really cool
or or maybe he's just like talking about
some pas
who knows or or like maybe you know
keanu's room in the halls or
jody comer or any of the other
big actors that have been hinted at
denzel could be back there we don't know
you know some of them might be coming up
multiple times like if if this was
happening when captain marvel was coming
out we'd have jude law coming out for
this and for marvel
and skarsgard in andoria and dr
juan carlos might be coming back out
later as a fan cast uh come true for
xavier
have to fight millie bobby brown for it
that's true that's true but she has the
powers so that's true
interestingly enough emily swallow who's
the actress that plays the armor in the
mandalorian yeah just said she uh she
got to meet amy sedaris for the first
time um i don't know if she's saying
backstage she got to meet amy sitters i
don't see her name in the list of people
who are
on stage but um it'd be very funny if
the armorer and amy sedaris's character
get to share scenes in the yeah that
would be hilarious um swallow also talks
about the the first few episodes where
the actors were trying to find a new
language um of these helmeted characters
right i guess it's probably hard to act
you know with just a helmet on and she
said you know uh what is it that
translates right um what kind of
movement are you reading what emotions
are you reading it was really a
collaborative effort what i quickly
learned for the armorer was that less is
more right she's kind of an imposing
figure right and doing a bunch of crazy
and not only that like barely
intimidating with her voice yeah she's
like pretty dry with what she says but
it makes it like land that much more and
i'll say one of the things i love about
the armor is that
her turn from like a protagonist to an
antagonist was really subtle and really
well done she was sort of like helping
uh denjaran in the beginning was like oh
here's you know all of the things that
you need to make my armor she's like i
got you fam and then over time she's
like if you take your helmet off i'm
gonna kill you yeah yeah with these have
you had it removed yeah these are
zealots right these are religious
zealots and that can be good or bad
depending on where you stand in their
zealotry yeah yeah and in this new
season you know as heath ledger's joker
taught us from that first scene with the
bank robbery just a simple head tilt
with your helmet on or mascot is the
creepiest thing in the world yeah now
whether
against their will or with their will
what are the odds we see a different
mandalorians face this season
we've gotten just the briefest glimpse
of
uh unhelmeted uh dome uh will we see any
other mandolin they have uh sabine wren
has been cast in the ahsoka show um
nicolette i forget her last name but um
but yeah so maybe she could be just like
ahsoka showed up maybe she could show up
maybe people in her family from the
animated show could show up so i think
so i think so and i guess it goes
without saying katie sackoff and that
whole band of mandalorians they don't
wear helmets they're kind of like beyond
that that craziness so like obviously
there will be something there are your
mandalorians yeah yeah
[Laughter]
a trailer here in a minute uh he said uh
he said it's very cute he said you have
something i want referring to the
audience at d23 and their love of star
wars he's hamming it up a little bit and
then he said it's the hero and the
heroine's journey that matters um and so
you know i think everyone's sort of
looking forward to what we hope is a
more streamlined story for the
mandalorian season three right in
seasons one and two it was a little
piecemeal we would have these sort of
like video game sidequest episodes every
night and they're also setting up other
series they needed to set up boba fett
they needed to set up ahsoka right yeah
absolutely um you know interesting maybe
they'll maybe they'll focus also if
you're like a big studio head get
giancarlo in all your franchises the
dude is the blast on stage at any kind
of announcement okay nobody has more fun
than giancarlo than any of that sure
yeah
those first two seasons of mandalorian
really reminded me of like hercules and
xena back in the day those like
adventure yeah
yeah i gotta do a thing but i gotta help
this person out to get to my ultimate
goal like and that's what really drew me
into the mandalorian at first uh when it
came out a couple years ago that's a
tough that's a tough uh balancing act
because it could easily become filler
and that's what you don't want and so
that was yeah again the meddler was so
great because there was very very little
filler if any at all you know that some
could argue so yeah hopefully season
three they keep that up yeah
absolutely well seemingly like expanding
like the
intensity right where it's less like to
feed a mud horn and more like save your
planet or your entire culture or
whatever right something big going on
very interesting john favreau has
referred to ahsoka as dave filoni's
magnum opus
i don't know if that means felony is
going to be stepping away from star wars
anytime soon or if it's just like the
culmination of everything floaty's been
working on this is the greatest thing
yeah imagine it's the latter because
yeah he lives and breathes uh star wars
you know like he's been a fan since
before he was ever a part of it and and
getting to work with this obviously he's
mentioned a lot of times before is his
dream come true yeah and i think they're
still grooming him to eventually be the
kevin feige of of the star wars
lucasfilm universe uh you know someone
already has that job but when kathleen
kennedy doesn't anymore i'm sure they're
gonna be quick to bring him in we also
have a quick uh we have a quick image
from the ahsoka show
that looks pretty fun i love my light
sabers i love them that almost looks
like uh a similar shot from that episode
with the um uh where she was fighting
that uh the magistrate with the best car
sure yeah yeah
you know i've been to a rave where a
person is dressed up just like that
real quick when you shout out a couple
super chatters a storm cutie 18. i'm
most excited for any mutant announcement
same same same storm same uh nolan wins
10 27 give me fantastic four or give me
death
um step back from that ledge my friend
uh but we i think we're gonna get it you
don't have to worry about getting death
and then um hannah king from canada
coming in as excited as i am for the
marvel announcements in star wars i'm
even more excited for the mufasa the
lion king yeah the announcement that was
we got some of those yesterday disney
announcements can we do a quick recap so
like just disney films in general
uh they had their panel yesterday and
now it's a little um
outside of the realm of normal new
rockstars uh content but can we do a
quick recap of some of the things that
were announced there let's talk so this
had been rumored but this is basically a
live-action lion king kind of spin-off
it's a mufasa origin story done in the
style of the live-action line king from
a couple years ago with donald glover
and beyonce directed by barry jenkins
who has not had a miss in my opinion
he's been a great director director of
moonlight director of amazon's
underground railroad series which was uh
brutal and fun and great uh and he also
directed if beale street can talk he's
well i wish i wish i remembered who who
tweeted this i can give them credit but
someone tweeted yesterday the movie's
going to start with mufasa falling into
the antelope gorge now you're probably
wondering how i ended up here and then
it's going to tell the whole story
i know i know a person who worked on a
crew of this project
and they said that like the technology
for this in particular is making a big
jump from the previous lion king wow
you'd think it was uh it was obviously
already pretty advanced for all the
faults of that that first live-action
lion king and usually that was john
favreau directed that yeah visually that
it was impeccable right he he you know
sort of famously was like yeah there's
one live action there's one shot that we
actually filmed
and some of it i was thinking is the
next level just real lions at this point
because you're right it looks so
freaking amazing um yeah supposedly
barry jenkins who's not a director john
just listed most of his filmography
who's known for big expensive cgi heavy
films but supposedly
he and kind of the studio have really
pushed things forward so like be
interesting when we eventually do get
some footage there of like what this
movie looks like okay so we have a
mandalorian season three trailer we're
gonna pull out
right now we have been getting a
copyright warning from
youtube youtube's copyright algorithm so
if we have to quickly cut away from the
trailer we'll do that but we're going to
pull it up and try to play it in its
entirety for you guys okay uh it's not
ready yet but okay
in the back it will be thank you
off-screen producer daschle there doing
the lord's work um also so other
projects that were announced yesterday i
believe a peter pan
film was announced uh a live-action snow
white
yeah
so these are these are
similar to the other live action like
beauty and the beast and the latter
these are retellings of the original
animated movies i think so mufasa is the
only new prequel type right right right
there was a trailer for disenchanted
which is the enchanted sequel
and a trailer for hocus pocus ii yes
which is coming out coming out sooner
yeah uh little mermaid live-action
little mermaid
yeah got a treasure for that so a lot of
fun stuff they also announced uh if you
guys are local to los angeles avengers
campus here in well i guess in anaheim
is getting expanded they're adding a new
ride i didn't know that really they're
adding a new right to that park they
sort of previously said that that was in
the plans back in 2019 when it was
supposed to uh launch uh until the
pandemic happened um but they've now
sort of confirmed like hey yeah we're
moving forward with this plan in the
park so we don't know exactly what
that's going to be but uh i wonder if
it's going to expand like into a new
area or if they're going to eat up some
of the existing because i think there's
no more avengers real estate left that
the park has something to tell you i
think it's going to expand sort of back
behind
where um
where mission breakout is okay parking
lot area yeah yeah we're going to go
into brandon we're here you can tell us
will be reporting back he's going to the
parks panel i think um that is tomorrow
i think he's trying to go to that so
maybe he'll have other park news which
again especially when it comes to
avengers campus is close enough to our
wheelhouse so we're happy to talk about
it
so while we wait for the mandalorian
trailer which we're pulling up uh right
this instant uh they have moved on to uh
20th century films and
a little indiana jones 5. so we've got
james mangled up on stage who's
directing the the newest indiana jones
uh movie indees back indeed
because that's done filming right yeah
that's that's done i mean right in the
indie fight i'm totally sure to be
honest with you well they they did do a
little bit you were at celebration i
don't know if you saw they brought
harrison ford out that's right williams
was there they showed us an image of of
indiana jones five so yeah presumably
they're either shooting or wrapped yeah
yeah there must be close to the rap if
they're not already yeah yeah very
exciting
very cool a couple quick super chats
we're going to shout out ricky lee who
do you want to see as part of the
fantastic four that's one of the big
questions of the day ricky uh we've been
speaking you know there's rumors out
there about jody come or as sue storm
there's uh rumors what are the other
john boyega was rumored
obviously john krasinski is uh front and
center as reed richards we don't know it
was that just an 838 a little gimmicky
i'll be surprised if it's john krasinski
as mr fantastic and not um emily blind
not emily
and it'll be jody comer i'll be kind of
surprised if they if they do that but
who knows they could think whatever they
wanted yeah maybe john krasiski's just
spaghetti 838 at this point who are your
guesses for ben grimm yes it depends if
they're going to go cg or if they're
going to go suit because we're going to
go cg like they could easily do i was
wondering i always wish they did a
little bit of mix like the force force
perspective like in lord of the rings
but you have a guy maybe in a suit that
looks real but then have him just be
actual large because sometimes the cg if
it's not there you know it'll take you
out of it well i'll go over that like
maybe a lot of that will depend on what
director is announced
for fantastic four if it's a director
that's known for lots of practical
effects
right like maybe they do try to make
something like that work because as much
as like
uh michael chiklis was trying his best
oh you know what i mean but it's tough
in a big thick foam suit
what's happening
okay here we go we'll come back to this
ricky uh we're gonna watch this main
delorean trailer definitely getting
demonetized
you know what it's worth it to bring it
to you do it for you guys
this is the one that you saved
[Music]
you are as its father
[Music]
a clan
of two
but you have removed your helmet
[Applause]
and you are a mandalorian
no more
your cult
fractured our people
where were you then
did you think your dad was the only
mandalorian
[Music]
all right kid
hang on
you ready for an adventure
i hope sooner than that oh my gosh i
told you all girl ghoul's coming back
baby looks so good we got a little taste
of mandalore in there a million
mandalorian uh of people in their armor
maybe some mandu on mando
wait i was like
what actually
some helmets are getting real close
i mean
all our familiar faces there um i gotta
say they've done an incredible job of
creating new characters in this world
that we care about right i feel like
star wars has really struggled with
creating characters that are not
han luke leia chewie etc um and and
having us really really care about them
but i i got a little misty watching that
trailer i was i was so i mean it was
like when when uh grogu and dinger were
in the little speeder and and or in the
ship and saying like you ready for an
adventure i was like uh i am ready
that's what we want the little guy in
his lap and then just cruising into some
some adventure yes one of the coolest
things about this particular trailer
that is don't get me wrong i love the
previous seasons but season two about
like a third of it wasn't even about dan
or grogu it was about you know luke and
about a whole bunch and ahsoka and so
this one it seems like it's more
contained it's more their story and it's
their adventure and it'd be cool to see
a full season fleshed out where we're
not having a you know sidestep to go
talk about other stuff which we all love
and which was great but it'd be cool to
get to see them all have their own
adventure in this by the way uh it
should be known uh india they've they've
shown a clip from indy 5. it doesn't
seem like we're going to get this one
but if we do i'll we'll pull it as soon
as we can but it seems like that one's
just going to be for celebration
audiences and or excuse me uh d23
audiences and just so you know we're
going to have tommy bechtold brandon
barrick we might have eric voss we might
have coy jondro kind of reporting to us
live after the panel so they'll describe
exactly what's happening in these clips
if we don't get to see the footage so
we'll let you know as soon as we have
more information about that
um real quick uh janice
julie's uh in the super chat brennan
fraser has the thing he's making a
comeback it is a brand renaissance uh
right now
i don't hate that idea that's pretty
good here's a and i'll just quickly
describe sort of what what people got to
see in that indiana jones clip if you
don't mind
they say we see we see a desert scene an
underwater scene which is i think new
for indiana jones um
and uh even a classroom scene uh so back
we're back at university uh and then
they they hear indiana jones say i've
come to believe it's not so much what
you believe it's how
this doesn't make sense it's how hand
you believe it
how hard you believe it may be great
and we hear the famous theme slowed down
a bit classic 2022 trailer right there
uh intercut with a lot of very actiony
scenes including indiana jones riding a
horse on us on a subway track this time
instead of regular train tracks maybe a
little homage to the beginning of um
of uh
the movie yeah last crusade um also
apparently a lot of people in the chat
saying uh harrison ford crying on stage
oh oh getting him
are we sure he wasn't maced
i'm sure he didn't cut some onions we
don't know but we assume he's getting
emotional because he's like phoebe water
bridge is going to be in this film um
and it sounds like uh james fangled has
described her as the foil to harrison
ford to indiana jones she's the villain
that could that's that's like sean
connery in last crusade right it's
technically his foil they're both kind
of on the same side of good and evil
there yeah so what about that subway i'm
curious uh you know i don't i'm horrible
at math but where are we in the timeline
now right because indiana jones is in
the 30s and the richmond doesn't work
out so
this would be like the 17th
60s was that the last time kingdom of
the crystal skull we had gone for it was
firmly into the like late 50 mid to late
50s you know
because they're still nazis running
around they were still nazis but it was
obviously like post-war i think right
and obviously if we're just following
the age of harrison ford this would be
i mean it's literally 2022 then
40 years after the first film is set
right like so it would be the 60s or 70s
um but whatever the kathleen kennedy has
left the stage that seems like the king
1957 57 was was crystal
and someone in the comments says it's in
1969 in the indiana jones five um maybe
maybe
uh
kennedy is off the stage and it is time
for marvel well we're jumping straight
to the market
what we're gonna get from 20th century
today we're hoping to take a little
bathroom break during the 20th century
and to be honest with you the avatar
sounds fun um but no rest
big hitters coming maybe they were like
uh nobody cares about the 20th century
anyways let's kick it or like that we'll
put that at the end as the hall slowly
filters out as people want to avoid it
right yeah
avatar again yeah yeah real quick as we
wait for this to kick off and um our
lord and savior kevin feige to take the
stage we're all drinking uh from some of
the official new rock stars um merch
mugs that you can get at
newarkstarsmerch.com now there are two
different mugs yeah that end of the
table have chosen the wrong mugs no that
is a design created by
uh
cast mate tommy bechtold after his
signature segment mandatory fun it's
fine but not that cool
look at how [ __ ] cool this is
it's cool but not as cool tom and i are
repping the much cooler it's morbid time
uh version of the mug now
depending on which one you prefer if you
have good taste or you know kind of
questionable taste uh you can vote on
which one of these is going to become
the permanent new rockstars break room
mug by buying one at
newrockstarsmerch.com all the time
there's a link right there in the
description and hey one of these mugs is
going to die at the end of this week uh
at midnight on sunday one of these mugs
is going away forever and based on
yesterday's show we learned that the
morbid time mug is a little is lagging
behind just a little bit so if you want
a chance to get an it's morbid time mug
which is maybe the
best mug i've ever heard of in my entire
life
you only have until maybe sunday to buy
this mug until it maybe goes away
forever because the mandatory fun mug it
is yeah this is going to be dead stock
real soon
if zach's bug doesn't get picked he's
already promised to go and break each of
the remaining ones himself
this is your last chance
i questioned some of the tallying i
heard dominion voting was uh
that's a good point that's a good point
hey so uh kevin feige is on stage and
this is fun this is a little fan
movement from kevin feige he says i'm a
little shell shocked we just saw some
indiana jones footage holy toledo a good
reminder that uh so many of these people
working at these companies or fans just
like us
absolutely they gotta be um real quick
uh let's recap what we're anticipating
here from from most
uh we're about to see it to farthest out
in the future right we might get we
might get some more wakanda forever
stuff that's the next movie that's the
next project we got i mean they had a
big presence at comic-con we got a lot
there but we could get a little bit more
today and then after that right the next
film ant-man and the west quantomania
we've seen nothing from that so we might
get some footage maybe an early teaser a
trailer we've all yeah we've only seen a
poster and then
films next year we're getting four
movies on the daca uh next year in order
quantum mania
guardians three now we already we saw on
twitter james gunn is not going to be
there but that doesn't mean they won't
dave batista might not roll in there
your your pratts your your zaldanas we
don't know uh we might see some footage
from that after that the next film late
summer 2023 the marvels okay heavy t's
there at the end of miss marvel we know
they're working on that film maybe we
get a little footage maybe who knows uh
tiana paris just uh announced she's
pregnant so um
hopefully she doesn't do any stunts at
uh
uh and then uh the final film in
november of next year play
oh yeah great uh
i want to tie a bow on the indiana jones
stuff
just so you guys know it's going to come
out june 30th 2023.
uh it's uh uh going to include a little
bit of aged harrison ford we'll see uh
disney's done that well and they've done
it poorly yeah so we'll see we'll see
michael douglas treatment yeah yeah and
and then alden ehrenreich
can do it okay is this going to be like
that um or was it the irishman where
he's dh only like three years and it's
like wait is he being aged at all yeah
is it happening uh harrison ford of
course says it's his last one so now
that uh marvel is out uh eric vos is
probably losing his mind they're doing
roger's the musical live for the
audience what yeah i mean probably just
that one number but amazing who knows
who knows uh
maybe they don't maybe they'll announce
that it's coming to disneyland and real
quick you've quickly mentioned zoe
saldana i i bet the farm she's there
because
guardians three and avatar yeah oh my
gosh all right
and that actually that could explain
um maybe why 20th got moved to the end
here maybe they're just doing a big
avatar it's a little avatar right i'm
just announcing the next five of them
yeah right right 14 of them uh and then
real quick the series that we're getting
just next year just 2023 okay uh none of
which have we really seen footage
trailers teasers anything for in order
secret invasion coming uh spring 2023 we
don't have an exact date maybe we get
that today maybe we see any footage uh
echo coming uh shortly after that kind
of spring early summer loki season two
okay give it to me hype hype let's see
something let's get hiddleston out there
okay uh and then later in 2023 we're
getting both iron heart which we know
they've been filming they might already
be wrapped on that even and then agatha
house of harkness which other than a
couple alternate titles we know nothing
about um so excited for any of that and
obviously if there's big casting in
those other than the leads that could be
a cool thing right like bringing out any
any cast members for
as as of yet unannounced for like blade
for marvel's right would be really cool
and then obviously that's just phase
five oh my gosh we are just next
year 23. uh and then going into
the following year in phase six right
like that's when we might get some
fantastic four news both the director
hasn't been announced or confirmed in
any of the casting uh anything about
secret wars or thunderbolts the big tent
pulls of that phase right we don't know
cass director or you know directors have
been announced for some of those but no
big casting news yet and then the big
hole in the lineup that everybody's
waiting on awards
are we going to see an x-men project
somewhere on one of these lines cool
right deadpool
along with that right well yeah other
than that next ninety-seven
which we're pretty sure we're gonna see
some footage from uh including some of
the other animated uh marvel
products like uh marvel zombies what if
season two yeah yeah uh all those
projects that you've named uh that are
just coming out next year those would be
prime real estate to start giving us
some yeah some casting announcements of
who else are going to be filling out
this show i mean you know agatha came
out of nowhere for i mean for me i don't
know about everyone else but in one
division as a breakout character they
could be introducing our next favorites
that we don't even know the madison show
people have been calling for oh that's
right right two ends in a while but now
we're here
which yeah kind of along those lines
right like obviously russell crowe was a
big kind of uh not well kept surprise
and thor loved that they could have
announced him ahead of time like we
don't know also like we don't know it's
been kind of rumored but i don't know
that we've seen confirmation that echo
will have vincent d'onofrio's kingpin
we'll have has been confirmed
also real quick before it happens who's
the most likely kind of like um the uh
high evolutionary coming out in full
regale yeah right who's most likely to
come out in costume at this
easy jonathan major this king
and
loki season two that's a good one just
going to town on an apple okay
just give that man multiple pieces of
fruit
yes yeah they got him busy for many
years so he's yeah he's got a lot of
this question i always wondered also if
kang and that apple was is kind of a
subtle nod to the apple in the garden
video probably just some religious
okay so maybe we're going to get some
more cool wakanda forever
maybe some uh armor armor wars because
an armor sorry um
yeah maybe they finally announced this
long rumored okoye disney plus series or
dora milage a disney plus series that
like he's supposedly a producer on as of
yet unslated unofficially announced um
real quick call out a couple super chats
aaron storm are you part of the
fantastic four storm family
uh first time getting to see break room
live super stoked to be here for this
today we're super stoked to have you
again this is a special saturday edition
because of d23 normally we're here every
weekday 3 p.m pacific 6 p.m eastern
broadcasting live covering whatever the
news of the day is john bad news bad
news exclusive clip being played of
black panther what kind of friend we'll
have a description that's right that's
right we do our best tommy beck told
will do his best to stumble his way
through
accurately describing this and we'll be
just as hyped to hear him describe it as
we would have been to see it maybe he'll
act it out for us actually yeah that
would be even better complete with the
wakandan english accent exactly
he should probably avoid that
i don't know the bill's won this week so
he's
um real quick uh avril in the super chat
saying my theory is fantastic for
casting director mutant stuff eternals
we haven't been talking about that
that's right eternal sequel announced at
some point in the next couple phases
starlight
pat oswald said said that he confirmed
that a turtle's two was being worked on
uh scarlet witch movie
i mean yeah people have been saying that
in the chat they missed scarlet witch
and want to know if she survived under
that pile of rubble at the end of uh
madness right somebody's saying in the
chat chris evans has been spotted oh
marvel's has been spotted who knows who
knows okay these could just be i miss
evans is
maybe it's just a tall jacked man
wearing a mask and we're just assuming
yeah you know that's a very funny uh
theory yeah yeah i've well i've i've
heard him uh talk about how it would
take it would be a tall order to bring
chris evans it would be a tall order to
bring him back to the mcu i was thinking
as cap as cap but with the multiverse
and that unfox the fox multiverse now
being considered a part of the mcu so he
could easily come back as human torch
what a baller move people have been
speculating hugh jackman might be there
to like introduce the new x-men cast
chris evans comes out to introduce both
sam wilson as captain america for uh
that new film uh captain america
and whoever's playing johnny storm right
and like just a kind of like pass
[Applause]
in the stream
he's there to announce uh what we're all
waiting for light year two oh yes please
with the world
but sorry to finish avril's uh super
chat because she had some good stuff in
there uh moon night season two
rumored whispered uh uh he's out there
making memes uh the director and
australia
out there kind of joking about it but
it's as of now unannounced and then a
midnight suns
film series
yeah we've got we know we got blade he's
coming sooner rather than later but like
nothing about ghost rider nothing about
any of the other characters that could
be at midnight sons that would be really
cool
um so we're we're patiently waiting this
news is probably going to drop drop fast
and furious yeah they make everyone put
their phones away during the clip and
the exclusive footage so we're not
getting any updates of anyone from like
uh this is a play-by-play of what's
happening until they can take their
phones out again you know and start
tweeting which real quick what are we
what have we not seen in wakanda forever
that we are equally anticipating there's
that image at the end of the trailer
where we see the
the snicked of the claws come out of the
black panther suit we don't know who's
in the suit i guess that's one of the
biggest mysteries still remaining right
now i have a theory about that but i do
have a quick description of the footage
if you don't mind breaking in uh we see
a u.n uh meeting with countries being
frustrated with wakanda about sharing
vibranium the queen i'm assuming angela
bassett's character uh responds about
not being worried about the dangerous uh
potential of vibranium but the dangerous
potential of you so like we don't want
to share our vibranium with you because
you're gonna mess this up yeah we can't
trust vibranium that we send you um so
that was that's the clip
so that seems to be you know there was a
really emotional moment in the first
trailer where she's like my family or
something like that it's probably the
same scene yeah yeah yeah i'm i'm
guessing you know the the
beginning of this movie is going to be
the world responding to wakanda you know
sort of saying like yeah we are a
country uh and we're pretty [ __ ]
advanced and the fallout from that right
the negative repercussions or whatever
and there has been speculation that when
angela bassett's queen character says my
entire family's gone that that's a scene
of her being alive during the blip so
maybe shuri was gone because she was
blipped she was blind she was like it's
a child
yeah uh the king had passed in uh
captain america uh civil
war
so she might have been you know going
off that and then that could be that
scene too where she's like yeah there's
half of everyone is gone but you you're
not gonna use that as an excuse
to take or by brady she goes on to say
in the clip uh that she hears what the
other countries are saying the king is
dead t'challa that uh their protector is
gone and then they see if they show a
very epic fight scene between the dora
milaje overcoming a large group of
soldiers which maybe is the scene that
took place on that boat we sort of saw a
bunch of soldiers you know something
like that uh yeah it's not obvious if
they're representing a country or if
these are mercenaries or hired soldiers
or whatever yeah yeah oh and brandon
thank you brandon uh in our slack says
uh it's the door milage preventing a
military team from stealing vibranium
yeah so what the government trying to
steal
that's fantastic
i can't believe that
ryan coogler has introduced leticia
wright uh winston duke tanakuerta and
angela bassett they're all on stage wow
so we'll get a little bit of words from
them so then uh my speculation on so you
asked things we didn't see in the first
wakanda forever trailer that we could
see coming up uh we saw riri williams uh
and sheree in the lab brief and we saw
her hammer out the iron heart uh so we
haven't seen her in the suit
[ __ ] [ __ ] up so i think she's
definitely gonna be putting action in
this movie against neymar and the
atlanteans fighting with um the dorm
elijah maybe these soldiers maybe
against these soldiers maybe she comes
to the rescue maybe she does floating
[ __ ] then also
uh i do have it there because one of the
black panther wakanda forever posters
that has come out is angela bassett
lupita nyong'o and uh leticia wright
shuri all kind of doing this and like
the shadow of a black panther is behind
the middle character yeah so what i
think might happen in the movie is a
kind of like handing off like here your
turn to be the black panther and the
three of them suit up
that way i mean like theoretically right
if you share the mantle of the black
panther you know there's always going to
be this protector of wakanda rather than
you know leaving it up to one specific
person i like that i hadn't thought of
that that's great well also as you
pointed out i think that was such a
great point that like some of these
scenes might be set during the blip
right and and we know that like this
film marks the end of phase four and
phase four has been all about dealing
with the repercussions of the blip so
like i think that's like a great point
if like if if queen if the queen
raimondo is the only kind of like royal
left maybe she does have to don the
outfit then
blip under you know we reverse the blip
uh shuri comes back now she hasn't done
it and they're like let's all do you
know they got a whole closet full of
those that's right like we can have as
many as we need to that that's really
cool i like that i would love to see
shuri's sort of iron man 3 phase where
it was just like i got too many suits
yeah
we could blow these up in a big
mouth for everybody yeah yeah good fight
yeah so uh it sounds like all of those
folks are now on stage uh tina cuerta
says that it was a wonderful experience
shooting uh on the film and that the
project is not just entertainment it
goes deeper than that and i think we got
a taste of that kind of storytelling
from that first trailer um if it's half
as deep as that trailer was
i'm already getting goosebumps again
just thinking like i saw a honk for
jesus last sunday in the theater and
what conifer rules one of the trailers
and whoa
from crying and yeah we've mostly been
consuming this like on our computers or
phones or whatever like to see it i mean
this film as part of the collective
experience in a theater
yeah they're going to be with people
right like with our friends well speak
for yourself
i mostly attend dog theaters
he buys out the whole theater
uh lots of people doing bits in the chat
about who's been spotted at d23 so we
said joe biden's been spotted
you said your mama's been spying you've
been spotted uh john cena that's where
she's been call me mom now
some of these could be legitimate but
they're all getting drowned out
but just from his neck down
oh yeah yeah
he's got goatee he can't shave
just his mustache has arrived that's
right
so now the question is they started with
black panther wakanda forever which is
coming out after a presumed werewolf by
night right that's coming out in
november they didn't start with the
thing that's coming out the soonest do
you think that means they're going to go
sort of in sequential order and we'll
get maybe a holiday special thing next
or maybe secret invasion next or do you
think they're just kind of going movie
movie movie
well don't you think yeah it does feel
like to go sequential except
if there's a bomb to drop right like
they're gonna end with whatever they
think is the biggest snooze that's gonna
really pop the crowd that's gonna get
the internet boiling so if that's a
casting thing if that's a new project
announced something like that maybe it's
just like kind of like the i don't
remember the order at comic con but you
know when ryan cougars on stage and they
had the musician kind of intro and it's
just like the biggest spectacle too
right you don't want to follow the big
musical segment you know what i mean
it's hard to follow music yeah
it could also be like whatever's going
to have the most footage or the biggest
trailer that might be the last thing
right yeah yeah so now a bunch of actors
from black panther were kind of forever
on stage talking about chadwick boseman
uh leticia wright says i'm excited for
my bro to look down on us and smile
uh and angela bassett says uh this is
the calm before the amazing storm and
that uh both coogler and bozeman uh
showed them the way uh which is right uh
storm confirmed storm confirmed
what better place than uh like i mean
she's in a lot of black panther comic
story arcs it's uh they're often
romantically linked and yada yada yada
yada was the queen of wakanda at one
point yeah so i yeah i i'm doing a joke
there okay
around a little bit but you know uh
following a thread iron heart is up next
okay
yeah we got to be seeing some footage of
that because we know they're filming
they are showing they are showing
footage uh in the in the audience right
now i don't know if we'll get to see it
but uh it there is footage yeah and so
we got another description for the
uninitiated we know the riri williams
character aka ironheart shows up in
wakanda forever she's in the trailer and
then she's getting her own disney plus
series iron heart late 2023 it's not
that far off almost exactly about a year
from now um
so this is clearly going to be a big
character over the next 12 months
absolutely can we show the phase 5
graphic real fast
let's see i wouldn't also i would
wouldn't be surprised too to see her
show up in something like thunderbolts
we don't know who's going to be kind of
yeah on the other side of that movie
yeah
i've been speculated as a young avenger
as a thunderbolt right like iron iron
excuse me armor wars is going to
probably fit in there somewhere so that
could be a place where it's still being
made yeah
yeah yeah i don't know that she was just
staring at his phone just waiting for
that phone call
put me in justice
yeah quick recap so again we started
with lucasfilm uh we got an announcement
of uh well it previously been announced
but tales of the jedi a short
serious animated yeah with some really
cool young dooku yaddle all kinds of
it's it's a lot of ahsoka's kind of
origin and backstory leading into the
ahsoka live-action series um we got our
first kind of look at skeleton crew the
next star wars film we think uh directed
by spider-man director john watts
starring jude law and some kids
i got a little bit of mandalorian we got
a mandalorian season 3 our first trailer
which was awesome uh some a lot of andor
stuff obviously that's coming out in a
few weeks a little bit about the ahsoka
series that will be coming out that's
the next series after andor but before
mando season three i think is that the
crate
no sorry it's after amanda season 3
first yeah so um kind of the next
year plus for star wars then we jumped
into marvel so far not a lot of
announcements we've uh we've mostly been
uh
hanging out with the cast of wakanda
forever yeah and speaking of which so
that it is confirmed the iron hair
trailer is exclusive for audiences at
d23 although again we'll have
descriptions of all this stuff after the
after the panel wraps brandon barrett
tommy bechtel maybe eric voss maybe koi
jondro will be here talking to us about
that but uh
in the in the footage uh rir williams
says i love this i want to build
something like him referring to tony
stark obviously and then she says but
you know better
hey i love the ambition right you
wouldn't say i want to build something
like him
keep things in perspective here's that
tony stark
anthony ramos is now on stage he's gonna
be playing the hood in this series
rumors rumors that maybe the hood is
sort of like an apprentice or working
with uh angela or um uh darkness oh
agatha okay yeah because he has like in
the comics he has like kind of a magical
cloak yeah he's kind of a character
connected to the dark magic yeah kevin
feige sort of was like hey uh ramos your
character a good guy or a bad guy and
ramo said he's a little bit above so be
interested to see who he's working with
and he's in iron heart yeah
kind of one of the only other castings
we know about for iron heart yes i
believe yeah
i'm hoping they announced some more or
some more characters or any of these
shows really yeah yeah yeah
um very cool well that's a good point
john i hadn't even thought about we're
getting iron heart late next year
followed by agatha house of harkness
almost immediately after that so like oh
is he a little connective tissue between
those two 23 series and also this is
interesting from brandon in our select
channel uh it sounds sounds like riri is
definitely at mit there was some
speculation that she might be in that
sort of oakland
outreach center that they set up in the
first place or movie sorry coy uh your
theory was wrong
sticking with the comics origin she's
definitely at mit yeah that's one thing
i i was missing from the iron man series
is i was hoping they would do like kind
of like uh the comics how the mandarin
is more magic and tony stark has more
technology having technology versus
magic and it sounds like if they're
going with the magical club from the
from the hood maybe that'll be where
riri williams comes in to help bridge
that gap speaking technology versus
magic speaking of which uh
kevin feige says having a character
rooted in magic and a character rooted
in technology is new for the mcu yeah
there you go we've always done either or
with like i mean i guess one division
and vision there's a lot you know
there's a little bit like that but like
what is this he's magical in that show
because he's a creation though yeah yeah
so we kind of got
iron man versus magic in uh infinity war
when he took on ebony maw and when he
went to space there's a little bit of a
little bit yeah it's a lot of
definitely versus a lot of crazy stuff
yeah so they they wrapped up the uh sort
of black panther iron heart portion of
the event no casting news about any of
that stuff unfortunately but they've
moved on to ant-man and the wasp
mania uh paul rudd evangeline lilly
jonathan mangers all on stage jonathan
is apparently wearing a hat and very
cool looking trench coat
nothing else
cool looking coat but not necessarily
king costume just maybe stylish uh actor
if i can find a photo of it i'll pull it
up but okay also yeah what's underneath
that trench coat
probably a 12-pack because he has
lots of muscles that's for sure
anything else oh this is fun jim rash
from community the dean and community is
apparently uh in ironheart i guess he
had a civil war where he was at mit he
was the one who had the idea about that
hot dog that self-warming hunting's like
tony i know gross but think about what
if he did this yeah
that's cool so they showed off some of
the new iron heart suits in the in the
teaser footage and it sounds like jim
rash is gonna be one of her uh
engineering teachers in the show so that
would be wow
there'll be some comedy for sure uh but
in in speaking of comedy and man in the
wasp right like and that that's a series
that has had a lot of kind of comedic
heavy hitters obviously from the top
down paul rudd but then like you know
cameos from neil hamburger and other
kind of noted comedic actors throughout
that and is bill murray confirmed like
that is in that movie he is in that
movie but has that been announced not on
stage well yeah
oh they did okay okay so we know that
he's in it for sure okay okay i didn't
know if it was still a rumored kind of a
thing or if it was official but yeah so
bill murray another comment yeah a lot
of heavy hitters there yeah he uh picked
up his phone and was like all right i'll
do this one
i'll take this paycheck
[Laughter]
bill murray famously does not have an
agent or really good ways of contacting
him you just have to call his phone it
goes to an answering machine and maybe
he answers it even if you're kevin feige
or whatever
good for him uh
this is very odd when asked about
him being the sexiest man alive paul
rudd says i've met michael b jordan so
you know that seems it's very very wrong
for him and then major says he knows uh
michael b jordan and paul rudd and to
him they're pretty much the same in
terms of sex wow wow also a lot of flops
here secret uh casting drop maybe we get
a killmonger return yeah we found it
forever interesting
yeah when would paul rudd michael began
other than like the secret marvel actor
maybe just
hollywood party the oscars whatever but
yeah they've never been in a film
together
interesting oh yeah has jonathan majors
and uh michael jordan have been in
anything
no no no i don't know either no that
could be another yeah an an equinox gym
somewhere
very diplomatic of jonathan majors you
know he has a preference one way or the
other but he's trying to stay on
everybody's good side he's very smart
with him he's yeah he's a charm he
hasn't made it this long in hollywood
for no reason that's right right right
right uh again thank you to everybody
throwing uh super chats uh out there if
you have any questions any speculations
any big reactions throw out a super chat
uh we will try to answer all of those
we'll scroll back through any that we
missed too later on in the show
um oh there's vo coming through new rock
stars this is my fav thing
two days to my birthday happy birthday
happy birthday hello virgo let's spa
yeah
here's a shot of uh jonathan major's
courtesy of coy johndra
there on the far left
uh wow
you know
the glorious photo i could have found
but i make a promise and i intended to
keep it i love it eventually it looks
like the matrix eventually lily's going
full white she's got white hair and a
white suit that's uh that's matrix
resurrections evangeline lilly right
there wow okay cool
uh yeah they're both their outfits are
our statement looks for sure i love the
big pockets on jonathan majors is uh
trench coat what's he putting in those
pockets
apples i mean a bunch of ants secrets
yeah squash squash hands
it seems like everyone on that stage is
very happy to be wearing uh clothes and
suits and stuff because this heat wave
of snaps
is uh functionally air conditioned
unlike this room
i will say paul rudd is talking a little
bit about quantomania he says this is
unlike anything you've seen certainly
from an ant-man in the wasp and then he
goes on to say jonathan majors is
incredible and throws this whole thing
into such new territory and now they're
getting another exclusive
look
ant-man and the wasp
we'll have our verbal descriptions of it
here for you i thought for sure we'd be
getting an ant-man trailer uh yeah
i mean they're going to be releasing
stuff sometime soon probably what is it
going to be marvel's mo is usually like
right before
a film drops we get the trailer for the
next film sure did we get kind of
forever right before thor 11 thunder
yeah right so maybe they're saving it
for black panther in a couple of weeks
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah maybe exclusive
you've got to go see it yeah
yeah i feel like we didn't get a lot of
lead up to thor four like i feel like a
month out we started getting maybe two
sure yeah i think maybe it's because
marvel now that they have so many like
disney plus series or whatever they
don't want to crowd out the market so
they kind of wait and do like a big push
in a narrow window rather than like
promoting these movies for years and
months right yeah and now that they're
like slate so stacked i mean we went
from you know like one phase having five
films so now we're like 10 deep and
we're almost as much less than a year
yeah now we're having that every year
where phases are done in like you know a
year and a half jesse waller coming
through in the super chat waiting for
more bs2 announcements
whatever time it is in the uk it's more
time
do you think they'll actually
because it made money didn't it no oh it
didn't not make a lot
bring it back a third time bring it back
a third time i'll go watch it sadly it
made a lot of my money
not sadly i had a great time with that
movie yeah we got to go and they invited
new rock stars
that was a lot of fun i love it i can
take more morbius movies yeah that was
great
if they did a second morbius movie i
would i would love it
in the theaters maybe it would surprise
a lot of us but even if it was of the
same quality as that first morbius movie
i would still have a blast because i
would go into it with that expectation
right and it only surprises us and you
know what this is this is mostly meme
talk here but like interesting thing
yeah what are we not definitely not
gonna see today
sony stuff
right yeah we're probably not gonna get
an announcement about the next
spider-man movie we are not going to see
probably not going to see anything about
madame webb uh the craven the hunter
film venom three
el muerte the russo yes that bad body
into the spider verse two and three
right like are we not going to be
getting any of that stuff today uh
interestingly sony doesn't have their
own d23 in which they can really roll
this stuff out they didn't do a lot at
comic-con either so hopefully at some
point we start getting more news about
all these different sony marvel
properties did they announce uh into the
spider verse three
yes or they said two parts
that's right yeah they announced it but
yeah we haven't seen anything from yeah
obviously and they push and they pushed
it back right right or they the first
part of yes right right
a couple other great super chats here
while we wait for more news to roll in
do you think we'll get a cameo by the
night stalkers in the midnight suns or
another mcu property since madison's
last name is king
i like where your brain's at math melody
you're doing some 3d chess there
and you know and she did go to that you
know demon dimension came back with a
human heart exactly yeah so they could
be trying to connect these things away
i've got i mean some people in the chat
are saying this too but randall park is
gonna be returning as jimmy woo and i'm
gonna watch spontaneous over here we had
sort of heard i mean jimmy wu not part
of that like crew but uh david dash
million said he wasn't coming back uh
t.i
said he wasn't coming back
michael payne
that that characters like jimmy woo are
going to be back in in the mcu uh
because they are they are truly my some
of my favorite parts
yeah absolutely and again like ant-man
by far the most comedic franchise yeah
but i mean
it sounds like from what they're saying
it might not be
quite uh they're gonna they're gonna
take this movie seriously i'm sure it's
it's still a marvel movie it's still
paul rudd's still in the lead peyton
reed's still directing i'm sure you know
maybe chris mckenna is still writing i'm
not totally sure i'm sure there will
still be laughs but i think that they're
you know this this movie is really
kicking off the kang sort of you know
dynasty dynasty right yeah i don't think
we're gonna we should be expecting a
she-hulk level comedy right yeah
the shadow hanging over all of us
is this thing happening when will we see
it when is it getting released well
we'll get as um you'll know by john's
head exploding uh when they announced
anything if they've shown it well i just
saw here that it says it's uh gonna be
directed by michael gianchino the
composer yeah yeah who's done all the
most amazing that that's john willis
previously kind of quiet
in the past and he was like yeah i'm
excited about it but he was really cagey
by the way i do want to quickly describe
some of the quantum mania footage uh it
sounds like it was the same footage from
comic-con uh where you know we had janet
and we had um
bill murray kind of saying like is that
you jam it um so it seems like they know
each other um but but also there's some
additional there's an extended scene
with kang he says something was taken
from him and only ant-man can help steal
it back so the king is reaching out for
help
and then scott scott apparently says no
deal and maybe that's going to enrage uh
enraged kang in some way or not anything
about how kang is dressed
that's the outfit the trench coat and
the hat that's probably straight don't
know what this is right the one kang
that we've met
functionally died at the end of
locations
brandon says the kangan a man of the
lost quantum media is definitely not he
who remains different characters and
everyone is describing him koi is
describing him as really menacing right
and he says you know in the in the uh
comic-con footage that we saw he says
like oh are you an avenger have i killed
you before right which is very different
from the sort of like jumping on the
desk he who remains that we got in that
season of loki so at the end of loki
season two we also saw the statue of you
know of jonathan majors kang there
that's not he who remains statue that's
a statue so is that the same kang even
or is that a different amount
even then that's part of the tv and
here's another description we see scott
lang having lunch with jimmy woo we see
cassie showing her dad a machine that is
sending a signal into the quantum realm
remind reminder cassie in the uh in the
comic-con footage was seen like getting
out of jail she was getting picked up by
and this is this is a recasty cassie
okay this is not the same actress who's
previously portrayed cassie lange uh and
then janet tells her to turn off that
that machine that's sending the signal
into the quantum realm but the machine
sucks the whole family into the quantum
realm feels a little ghostbusters or a
little honey i don't know
i shrunk the family they show bill
murray they see kang telling scott lang
you're an avenger have i killed you
before all that comic uh all that
comic-con stuff we had heard before um
and then he says uh you know they all
blew together after a while is what kang
says um so yeah um
so werewolf by night yeah people are
saying it's coming out next month uh of
course
you're right yeah i didn't i didn't
think they were going to be able to hit
that target but here we go people who
are unfamiliar with werewolf by night uh
night is a werewolf in marvel congress
i'm not super familiar with him but that
is the comic that moon knight first
debuted yeah so apparently we could see
a little bit of moon night uh i'm not
sure if this has been confirmed at the
panel i'll let you know if it has been
but there's been some rumors that it's
maybe
like just a fun kind of campy uh old
school type horror short maybe like 30
minutes all in black and white which is
kind of fun sort of harkening back to
those you know james whale type horror
films of the 30s and 40s yeah
so john uh excuse me uh michael jacquino
uh who's i think he's directed a couple
of things before like some short films
for some movies that he's worked on uh
so that he's they're sort of giving him
but no no casting as of yet for wolf uh
i've got gail garcia brennal
going to be in it and laura donnelly two
people i'm unfamiliar with gail garcia
bernal um has done a lot of stuff uh i
believe is he the guy mozart in the
jungle
is that him and traffic but he was in uh
um so is he the werewolf we don't know i
would bet
maybe okay
jack russell is the name of the
character yeah uh yes
exactly uh they're showing a clip now uh
i i hope they put that one online you
know that one feels like it doesn't need
to be so exclusive yeah it's around the
month so yeah what's going on but they
gotta drop a pipe for it now yeah
and again we think that's gonna be a
disney plus exclusive there probably
short again kind of dropping in the same
vein as the iron groot shorts and some
of the other things they've plopped on
there
but we're
jazzed for it well and and i feel like
this is maybe as much of a confirmation
as we're going to get although they are
playing a clip right now werewolf by
night but the title card itself
um is in black and white oh
okay we can get that on screen now also
favorite cinematic werewolf are you a
werewolf in london america from london
are you a benissa del toro
like the werewolves in uh harry potter
also sure
hey daschle can we show up throw that
title card real fast
yeah it looks good
radio silence
oh there it is there it is
very cool similar to moon knight special
presentation i like what it is that
sounds cool yeah it does look very moon
mighty you're right absolutely yeah whoa
possible connection yeah
possible connection there were rumors
that you know there was rumors that were
fine would show up in midnight i don't
know if that was cut or if it was just
batting
or was that just people misunderstanding
the uh egyptian uh wolf
characters the trailer is out so we're
gonna pull that for you guys oh here we
go as soon as we have it okay great real
quick while we wait for that a couple
other um
super chats noob master saying off topic
but is sheridan carter sony birch's boss
maybe we get an answer to that in
quantum mania oh yeah who was who is
sunny birch working for in ant-man of
the wasp we never found that out uh
nolan wins 10 27. timmy wu better have
more magic tricks if you think for a
second jimmy wu isn't coming with some
next level sleight of hand uh you sir
are mistaken i mean this would be so
cheap and i would hate it in actuality
but wouldn't it be fun if the foil to
one of these kangs was just slight of
hand magic magic
it distracts them
infinite at least one of them's gonna
get a trick one of them is an easy mark
yeah yeah totally
um okay great uh another 22 saying i've
always been cast brendan fraser is the
thing
um yeah he's his his energy is out there
right now people are saying he's an
oscar favorite for his work in the whale
um obviously he connects to 90s kids
uh elder millennials middle millennials
who enjoyed the mummy series encino man
and george of the jungle georgia the
jungle
watch out for those trees any bedazzled
stains that was one of my that was one
of my favorites
and while we wait for this trailer to to
well we wait for this trailer real fast
it's coming out on october 7th so it's
actually pretty close
it's it is gonna be in black and white
uh brandon describes it as looks weird
as hell old school and now they're
showing a trailer for secret invasion
okay so folks we're gonna have
back-to-back hot trailers for you
yeah
exciting i like a weird as hell old
school for a while by night why not
whatever it's gonna have that grainy
film uh feel to it maybe even in a four
by three aspect ratio just like a really
old school
thing that would be hilarious i have a
little bit of a preview of it it looks
it looks pretty it looks like they just
like turned on a black and white filter
so it's not like uh the lighthouse with
uh
you know it was like we're going to
shoot a film
or logan they're going to say here's the
black and white version yeah yeah
there's a black and white version of
logan oh yeah oh [ __ ] yeah i think it's
on the 4k blu-ray i think it's funny
that directors like george miller did
that for uh for uh
uh i love that um people in the chat
asking will werewolf by knight be rated
r i don't know but i can almost 100
percent guarantee no it's gonna be on
disney plus okay so i'm gonna try to
take care of the secret invasion trailer
because apparently that's out great
i want to show that first so we're
working to get you both of these
trailers as soon as we can okay if
anything's going to be rated why don't
we show we'll show the werewolf by night
trailer really quickly wow while we work
on getting the secret innovation trailer
all right great
[Music]
halloween
you can't escape the shock
the terror of
werewolf by night
tonight
it is every hunter for themselves
good luck
i'll be
rotting for you
but one of you is a monster
masquerading as one of our own
i can't wait to find out what breed of
evil you are
[Applause]
[Music]
please don't do this
gas is coming for you
[Music]
[Applause]
werewolf by night
it's like very old hollywood but also
mixed with like the horror movies that i
used to make you know at home when i was
like
i think completely unlike anything we've
seen in the mcu so far
absolutely
they did that special presentation thing
as if they're going to be doing more of
you yeah i wonder if that's what we'll
get for the holiday special yeah
something like that something
their way of announcing this is not a
series this is not a film maybe also
their way of announcing this doesn't
connect to anything else who knows
but wild like if you'd just seen that
trailer didn't know it was made by
marvel
you wouldn't think that that was a
marvel right now right now well you
pointed out it's sort of like werewolf
the
game or mafia
one of you is a werewolf right
secret werewolf yeah
um yeah great also so hinted on that
trailer that gabriel garcia bernal is
the werewolf but also we see him getting
grabbed now maybe that's him getting
kind of first bitten and there were
other creature type yeah
i wouldn't be surprised if it was just
like a rich people got a bunch of
ghouls and ghosts together and were like
you know yeah there's some like squid
game element there there's a little the
most dangerous game somebody's saying
did i see jessica jones i don't think
that's kristin
i don't
i don't know i could be wrong but it
looked like the same actress who was in
umbrella academy who played that one one
of the sparrows
she was she was the one next to her in
the melted he's got that would you say
the one who spits the one who spits it
looked like it might have been her but i
don't know
it didn't look like kristen ritter but i
don't think it would be her and i think
they're saving either not to use her
ever again or they're saving her for
jessica jones and some sort of daredevil
introducing the netflix characters real
quick all of these trailers maybe not
world fat night but probably even
werewolf by night we'll be breaking
these down on the new rockstars channel
eric vos specifically will be going
frame by frame picking out all the
little details especially the ones that
are getting publicly released now like
the wakanda forever footage the the uh
quantum mania footage that's not getting
publicly released he would probably
still do a recap video where he kind of
covers because he's there in the hall
watching these so just from memory he'll
be doing a breakdown we won't have the
footage there uh until that's released
but um then anything else any trailer
like the secret invasion trailer that
we're about to watch
we can't keep up they're on to armor
wars now we have a new title card
something interesting is happening yeah
yeah sure uh do we have our secret
invasion trailer we're still working on
we're still working on some conversation
we'll have that for you as soon as we do
armor wars is going to start shooting
next year
a little okay so we're okay so i'm not
seeing that until 2024 yeah yeah
um mike mike cairo in the chat scene man
thing confirmed you know i was going to
say that same thing in that trailer i
swear
eric will break it down first but there
was a moment where it looked like uh the
silhouette of the man thing's face and i
was and so that's what was making me
think there's gonna have a lot of
monsters in this maybe vampires like
what we talked about in morbius with
blade coming up i also saw that man
thing moment i know exactly what you're
talking about and it was just a
silhouette and it was a flash of a
second so of his face we're about to
we're about to move on to uh we're about
to watch the secret invasion trailer we
haven't ready it sounds like armor wars
is going to lead right or secret
innovation is going to lead right into
armor wars and now they've been done to
loki's season two so let's watch the
secret invasion okay trailer
i think
for years
you've been avoiding earth
i have called for your help plenty of
other times and you've been pretty
content to let those calls go straight
to voicemail
yeah well
this is different
how much you know about your security
detail
what do you mean how much do i know
about him
fury
we're gonna be very careful now
the stream was going to get taken down
uh if you want to finish the rest of the
trailer it's out now on youtube and
twitter this is the same footage that
they showed at comic con um it looks it
looks pretty it looks so cool
uh yeah and again we will have a full
reaction and breakdown on the channel
just what we were able to see before the
our evil overlords at uh
google and disney threatened our lives
um so and now they're talking about
loki's season two so i'm just gonna i'm
gonna get into that news they're moving
kevin feige only has 90 minutes in
anaheim and he's getting through
everything so tom hiddleston's on stage
with uh owen wilson and sophia dimartino
who plays uh sylvie uh and it sounds
like season two is gonna start right
when season one left off right in that
uh post-credits scene or that last scene
where
he's like i'm back in the tva no one
knows who the hell i am and there's a
kang section and there's the king statue
uh so and then feige says that season
two is gonna connect right into the
multiverse saga so i wouldn't be
surprised can we pull up that phase five
graphic real fast
that's sitting right there in the middle
i wouldn't be surprised if that's gonna
tie into i don't know i don't even know
what multiverse projects are there maybe
the marvels yeah who knows what one of
those other projects are going to be
multiversal maybe deadpool maybe agatha
against the house of hearts
yeah yeah absolutely uh and and they're
showing a little first look of loki
season two that i bet we're not to get
online but we'll describe that to you as
soon as we can
uh real quick circling back to that
secret invasion the vibe on this right
like very spy thrillers
espionage right if you're a fan of like
you know tinker taylor soldier spy or
like uh films like that all those kind
of british very you know uh
days of the con condor and all that kind
of stuff like has that energy and the
music you know yeah and just a stacked
cast absolutely of grown folk actors you
know what i hated about you know what i
hated about that trailer some of the
scrolls
i mean obviously they're not going to
write me around the trailer
interesting the one of the last shots we
saw before we had to cut out was ben
mendelsohn's character confronting that
guy and then there's five other
maybe
um
copies of him is this a multiple man
type situation or maybe they're all
scrolls pretending to be the same
character right one thing interesting is
we saw rhodey in that and he's been long
rumored
it was really fun in captain marvel to
get the twist that the squirrels were
good and not evil but i was definitely
missing having them be some big bads you
know coming out so to see that we might
be actually officially getting that
maybe it's a different sect of squirrels
or whatever and uh squirrels contain
multitudes right you're probably gonna
get some good scroll bed scroll action
oh yeah yeah well maybe yeah it sounds
like um and i'm sorry if i'm pronouncing
this name incorrectly kehoi kwan who is
in uh i mean obviously no in uh
everything everywhere all at once oh
yeah
and temple of doom and goon and all that
kind of thing he's gonna be in loki
season two oh he is oh that's so great
glad to see him getting oh my gosh
lately she's fun he's the best yeah
gonna be that'll be a blast that's
awesome but back back to secret invasion
love that look on nick fury oh you're
throwing the beard out
[Applause]
oh man it looks so good and just
interesting too i mean obviously it's
going to be dealing with outer space
scrolls however but i love that we're
just seeing people with guns back in the
mps you know what i mean you want to
know what they're moving on to next what
are they moving on to
fantastic four
is up next baby oh my gosh okay give us
the director the dog's excited for
fantastic not a drill not a drill
okay man what a good day what a good day
i know they're not they haven't filled
in any new movies yet uh we still have
what do we still have an hour to go on
this panel i can't remember um top slime
oh gosh
it is it is it has been fruitful you
know i hope they still announce more
movies who knows matt ackman confirmed
to direct okay fantastic it's out there
it's been rumored for a couple weeks
yeah uh so he's he's coming on from one
division he directed all those episodes
obviously we saw some really cool sort
of fantastic four esque looks when when
you know uh photon was sort of going
through her transformation that was that
sort of felt like the right kind of tone
and world that they would be doing uh
people in the chat are saying krazynski
i don't trust the chat at this point
i'm waiting for mine we'll wait till we
see some of our in-house connections
there again we've got oh it sounds like
it sounds like they're moving on to echo
oh
no
we only got
and they're showing a video uh with
captions for echo of course she's
awesome hearing impaired yeah um so
that's that's pretty interesting very
cool wow shockman does not come up on
stage
no uh
they say nothing for him to talk about
and and they move on oh man fight you
tease now again this movie is 20 24 four
it's a ways out i believe yeah
for some casting but
you know you know they could still have
people come out at the end like
us maybe yeah they could totally blade
us yeah circle back um and and so real
quick yeah as john kind of mentioned no
new projects mentions other than
werewolf by night which they were just
sitting about right like they were they
were uh sneaking that one right under
those armor wars had previously been
announced but this is sort of the first
time they uh you know talked about it to
talk about it and now did they did we
get a confirmed like where i don't like
date or anything like that for armor
wars other than the fact that uh secret
innovation is going to lead into armored
work
which is interesting it's like um secret
invasion's kind of like a backdoor
season two or armor wars is a backdoor
season two for a secret invasion right
and you know roadies in both right both
of those shows could kind of feed into
yeah i love that they have that they're
they're definitely covering the entire
spectrum of marvel here with you know
with werewolf by night being you know
like kind of a noir
horror thing after echo being a very
street level thing that we have outer
space things so
echo footage
there have been rumors that they were
going to kind of play with her heritage
and how that sort of gives her some kind
of powers uh being like native american
ancestry and so now it seems like in the
footage that they showed there's a fight
scene and they see echo looking at her
hands and their hands are glowing and
then they do flashbacks into history
there's grenades there's a little bit of
kingpin
uh and now the echo cast is coming on
stage uh vincent d'onofrio al-aqua cox
uh no uh no uh charlie cox no charlie
cox
you know what's interesting is that
about her hands glowing because in the
comics recently she became the new host
of the phoenix force oh really yes she's
the new phoenix i think she's currently
the phoenix in the marvel universe so i
wonder if they're setting up some seeds
there yeah i mean in her introduction in
hawkeye she's a badass fighter but we
didn't see any hint right supernatural
or otherwise powers right yeah it sounds
like uh it sounds like emma footage
kingpin's donning that iconic yellow eye
patch after he gets shot in the end of
hawkeye and of course that's a line in
the comics as well that they're going to
bring into this season
yeah
uh real quick john dunham in the chat
what if don cheadle rhodey is a scroll
and they're getting uh terence to come
back
that would be nice that's very phase
four of them right with with some of
these sort of fan castings or the winks
and the nods with both the she-hulk and
multiverse black bolts there yeah
showing back up um hilarious i don't
know uh that parents would be so down to
reprise that
choice words that he said yeah if they
backed up the brinks truck i bet that
maybe he could be okay yeah
might not like that to be like what's
going on again
[Laughter]
i care so much
yeah
but that's a good one uh sir psycho
sidekick saying uh the one in umbrella
academy is larry david's daughter i
think those who actually said you were
referencing earlier so is she the one in
the trailer uh yeah she looked like it
could have been her maybe
interesting we'll get now we're getting
some reporting from our
on the ground um
uh tommy bechdel most of his
correspondences have been uh
um tough because his phone's been
covered in tears since harrison ford
came out on stage they might have broken
they might have broken tommy bech told
but he'll be uh tommy and brandon uh
from the break room cast will be
reporting back they've been in the hall
watching all this footage uh seeing all
these trailers and announcements and as
soon as the panel is wrapped they're
going to call in to us and report back
on everything they've seen so stick
around for that
yeah it sounds like they're showing some
some footage from uh oh we already sort
of talked about that all the loki stuff
the the actor from everything everywhere
all at once is playing sort of like an
archivist at the tva so a little bit of
like uh probably the role that uh eugene
cordero was kind of uh yes but i was
gonna say from everything everywhere all
at once that jamie lee curtis played
that would be fun to see the tax person
or something yeah yeah there's nothing
similar to that that's great
um let's see cody lightning uh one of
the actors in echo says learning asl was
rewarding and that he plans to continue
to learn a lot what cox was on stage
signing that this was only the second
role that she had ever had she i thought
she was great
oh yeah um
uh and so some of the other casts we're
talking about it sounds like the whole
cast sort of did a lot of research and a
lot of learning asl for this show
because i imagine there's going to be a
group of people that are just signing to
each other and we're going to get a lot
of that similar to like i think there
was a episode of master of none where a
lot of that a lot of that episode was
just all signed and with subtitles so i
think that'll be a really cool one only
murders in the building had a similar
episode uh built around a deaf character
yeah really fun interesting ways to try
to tell stories in different ways that
i'm excited to see it's going to be
really cool yeah and again this is a
corner of the mcu people are not as
familiar with we know kingpin and kind
of that whole daredevil world but like
it'll be really fun to explore in that
like it's not predetermined how this
story is gonna go and who else might
show up and what other kind of
characters develop the uh the filmmakers
here involved have a lot of freedom to
kind of tell this story uh the deeper
that we go into the marvel roster now
you know uh being 10 years out from
avengers 1 we're seeing all these
characters that yeah are new and that we
don't really know what their future
holds like when they're getting their
own shows now iron heart miss marvel uh
echo american chavez we're seeing all
these people come out where you know
we're we're we're not gonna be able to
rely on the comics anymore in terms of
being for a road map but we're gonna be
echo potential thunderbolt
oh you gotta think right that would be
uh oh yeah that would be she she
definitely is on that edge we see julia
let me dreyfus roll in at the end of
this series be like i'm putting together
a squad
maybe that's the casting that they'll
announce um you know all the
thunderbolts line up maybe that's what
we'll get at this at this panel
who knows again that's the next team-up
movie right the beginning right kind of
at the at the tail end of this upcoming
phase five right middle of 2024 is the
thunderbolts film yeah so like
presumably they're going to be setting
that up in a lot of these it's not going
to come out of nowhere um
uh chat's playing tricks on us they're
talking about a world war hulk film that
would be fun talking about deadpool 3
being called maximum effort which is the
quote from the first deadpool movie but
also ryan reynolds sort of production
company that would be fun also i got to
tell you these mandatory fun mugs might
look nice next to a maximum effort mug
yeah they don't look nice at all folks
again
by this mug that says morbid time at new
rockstarsmerch.com is a bit of a
competition uh whichever mug sells
better by the end of tomorrow will
become the official breakfast mug buy a
damn morbid time mug it's the funniest
thing i've ever seen in my entire life
it's quiet it's gonna go away it's got a
clock on it but all the numbers are
falling off because you know whatever
time it is it's more and more time
that's right then in the graphic style
of the opening credit sequence of morbid
uh
morbid
you know i i've said this a couple of
times but like 22 will be remembered for
good things and bad but the meme that
will survive that will bury us all
morbid time more than that's true
more times comes for us
and there's also lots of great other
merchant new
rockstars you know get your hi i'm eric
fosher get our cool new latest obsession
uh shirts that are built around house of
the dragon and she-hulk we kind of have
a limited edition shirt that comes out
for any like big series we're excited
about we'll have a cool one for andor uh
releasing in the very near future and of
course it'll be wakanda forever and
every big marvel star wars property
that's coming out in the future don't
trust anyone in the chat uh uh the echo
cast and crew is still on stage uh
vincent d'onofrio said it's a great cast
i was so impressed by all these people
that they're just amazingly talented he
also said to bring fisk and maya back
together with some absolute thrill and
now feige's on stage leading the
audience in a little asl applause for
the castle okay and then yeah it'll be
interesting to see what comes up next
now we've gotten of the disney plus
series that are starting next year
secret invasion got that echo got that
location
sorry against the house of harvest well
no uh it sounds like uh dinafria won't
leave the stage
wants to talk about daredevil oh
let's go
born again
oh sorry daredevil oh please
why wait
charlie cox is out on stage now won't
leave the
charlie cox is now on stage
um it's too bad he's not in full costume
that would have been my best for uh that
would have been a good one yeah
you like juan carlos esposito um vincent
afrio loves the kingpin character he
loves talking about it like happy
birthday on twitter
when the daredevil series was kind of in
the interregnum between netflix he was
very vocal being like yeah let's keep
this going and he got his wish yeah man
if we if we get more casting
announcements for born again i know
they're not going to have any uh any any
footage or anything but you know if they
if they want to bring back the actor who
does foggy
bring back karen page you know if they
want to bring back some of the cast you
know rosario she's there yeah maybe she
could come out i mean there's a lot that
could happen so they did do a little
there was like a sizzle reel playing in
in the hall yesterday at d23 if you were
there in person and they debuted this
new daredevil logo that we can throw up
on screen real fast so you get the
classic dvd
that's gonna appear on the new suit not
totally sure
uh but that's very exciting it sounds
like they're gonna start shooting next
year so obviously we're not gonna get
any footage or anything like that it's
so interesting uh looking at even like
the the released photos of daredevil and
his new suit granted it's it's a yellow
and red one but if you look closely it's
it's the same design as a netflix show
yeah exactly
just just with a different color scheme
and maybe with a dd added so they're
probably picking and choosing the best
parts of the netflix
exactly
and that's a comic run right yeah it is
so it sounds like they're not showing
daredevil footage obviously because they
haven't shot anything but they are
giving uh folks at d23 a little bit of a
look at daredevil in she-hulk so we
still haven't seen any daredevil
episodes of she-hulk yet there's some
rumors that that's not coming until a
little bit later in the season i want i
want every episode yeah yeah
but uh it sounds like they're getting a
little bit of that treat now and of
course we'll describe all this footage
for you in a second it'd be cool if you
know since they put the dd in the logo
for daredevil born again there's some
multiverse madness happening and we get
an appearance from batfleck
oh wow oh geez
you know flash whenever that comes out
because he's probably better flicking
that and then aquaman ii
yeah so they're showing some stuff that
we had you know there was a clip the
mid-season trailer for she-hulk came out
yesterday showed a little bit of matt
murdock uh this they're showing a little
bit of daredevil he's in his yellow and
red outfit he says goons and henchmen
are completely different animals i don't
know i guess there's a differentiation
between a goon and a henchman
i'm not sure uh but also it says looks
like there's some chemistry between
daredevil and she-hulk which i i'm going
to read into and say we're different
from the chemistry between matt and jen
right um so it does seem like you know
who knows that's a fun as i think it was
you yesterday that pointed that out uh
tom it's a little bit of uh batman
returns right both the bruce wayne and
the selena kyle character surviving
while alter eagles are vibing yes
catwoman characters are all surviving
yes
uh very cool yeah we're excited for the
rest of she-hulk we've been covering
that here um jessica clemens uh cast
member of the break room's been breaking
that all those episodes down on the new
rockstars channel
uh check out the breakdown of episode
four that's out a couple days ago uh
it's great and again we'll be breaking
you up down all of those for the rest of
the season um very cool a couple yeah
folks saying all kinds of fun stuff in
the chat i want to shout out uh
sundari 419 randall park also as reed
richards
that would get a little complicated well
randall park was uh josh krasinski in
the office so that was so that's what
that's i think he's a joke on that so
yeah good reference so it'll still be
john krasinski is what you're saying
yeah yeah yeah yeah i got you i got you
graveyard depraved gourd our friend
who's often here in the in the chat even
with my cold heart zaddy i'm glad you
are okay
yesterday on the show uh tommy bechdel
and i ate the one chip challenge lady of
the trap style i might have lady in the
trap we started concerning open ends of
the chip and met in the middle um and
both of us will never be the same no
yeah a lot of people are concerned about
you in the chat
tim blake nelson coming back as the
leader yes for captain america new world
order no
maybe we'll see him and joke a little
bit but but definitely coming back to
captain america new world order and
again tim blake nelson great actor oh
brother where out there a million other
great projects um
but he was um right first appeared in
the ed norton uh hulk right he's the guy
that samuel had the weird goo get get
dripped on his head and his legs
was the hulk blood so there so when they
had jennifer walters get the blood in
her too they're tying that same that
same thing where if the hulk's blood
gets into you there's gonna be problems
yeah if you survive sounds like the
director is now on stage with anthony
mackie and they're sort of uh discussing
uh this movie calling it a thriller
which is maybe similar to uh captain
america winter soldier which would be a
lot of fun that's you know i think a lot
of people's favorite or are right up
there in top five for sure let's get
let's get into more uh fishing boat
economics okay
you know i'm not kidding i really
enjoyed that i would like to know like
what is what does the engine repair cost
yeah okay what does the jesus look like
yeah what are the diesel prices doing to
his operation down there in louisiana uh
but no we're we're excited for that new
world order film and like who's
potential antagonists in that crowd well
the leading products exactly
yeah so along with the new daredevil uh
title card that they showed uh yesterday
we also have a new captain america new
world order titles card which you can
flash up there fans of the break room
kind of mixing the falcon and the
captain america logos together that's
great that's really good it looks really
cool very cool yeah
and also the color scheme of um
the the costume that he had in the final
episode right yeah also in the comics he
has a new shield and it's it's a similar
color scheme too and uh if i wonder if
they're gonna bring that in maybe
because it may give sam wilson his own
type of shield as opposed to one pass
down by steve that'd be really cool yeah
yeah
so the leader is gonna be the villain in
in and captain america four that's
interesting interestingly enough to be
in there interestingly enough carl
lumley is going to come back as isaiah
bradley yeah
he was one of the best parts he was so
good we loved him and that we wanted
more for him we saw him like stick one
thing into a wall but no other display
of the super game does this mean we
might get a little elijah bradley a
little eli bradley oh i'm sure we might
be a lot of fun long rumored as a
potential young avenger himself yeah i
hope they have some flashbacks with the
dh uh lovely going in there being oh man
that's how you get uh chris evans back
oh yeah he would have been a nice never
mind oh i said i didn't know timeline
doesn't work out um also tom constantly
standing for de-aging here oh yeah i'm a
big fan because i want to use it myself
uh oh yeah one of these days soon i
already lost my hair guys i need to age
the rest of me as quickly as possible so
yeah let's get on that you just explore
wigs tom you don't have to age yourself
there's a way to glue it onto my head
i'll do that to blow it away yeah the
wind would blow my wig right off on a
really breezy day you never know
uh oh uh max savage saying russo
brothers as new world order directors no
i think there is another confirmed
director is it the same uh
his name is uh his name is
julius ona oh okay i can't remember we
had reported on this a while ago he
hadn't direct
danny ramirez is also going to be uh
coming back if you remember he was sort
of yeah falcon jr from uh
from that show you can keep these wings
right asking if uh if it's true that
captain america or at the time is on the
moon
um
yeah that's fun that's fun casting oh
yeah that's shaping up to be a really
cool movie but i thought the director
the show runner from uh from uh the
captain america falco rashoda was going
to be doing cap four but malcolm
spellman yeah michael swapp and thank
you i think he's writing
tim blake nelson is back he's on stage
and he's talking about being the leader
he says i'm delighted marvel's a part of
cinema history and that i get to be a
part of that it's an absolute honor
seems like nelson if you're if you're
not super familiar with him uh if and
but you are a comic book fan he was in
most recently the watchmen series yes
that's silver mirror or whatever his
name was yeah mirrorball i think is that
his name or something like that also i
mean he played buster's scruggs and
ballot buster scruggs on netflix he was
uh along with um john detroit and george
clooney
yeah he's very good we are moving on to
thunderbolts oh okay
uh no problem interesting ghost
returning from ant-man and the y i had
to be in the thunderbolt thunderbolts
as well as red guardian which is going
to be a lot of water
in his back and task master we'll see
they like to do a little bit you know
they they probably heard some of them
the taskmaster or the
i imagine they'll like probably try to
do a little bit of uh tweaking of that
character if they could break tony
masters because there's a deleted scene
in the black widow movie where
she
well maybe what made in the final
cupboard she joins the widows and she
yes right and she's like officially good
and now she's been fixed so yes i wonder
if they're going to try to bring in uh
yeah tony master
stan is going to join the thunderbirds
uh also yeah um red guardian man what a
fun character
of course is on stage as well florence
pugh sent in a little video oh i was
gonna say is she gonna be in the
thunderbolt she and red guardian uh
florence pew would probably you know has
to take a few more showers after she
probably got some spittle on her
exactly venice is a hard place i do like
promoting thunderbolts harder than she's
promoting don't worry about that
uh to backtrack to new world order feige
says new world order takes place in a
world without avengers but there's
another group out there and that's when
they tee up the thunderbolts so maybe
we'll get a little bit of thunderbolts
in new world order uh but i i imagine
this captain america film will be sort
of setting up
phase six and how we get more avengers
or more young avengers or new avengers
or whatever and we've been we've been
fantastic to line up for thunderbolts
for years right even before the film was
announced hi this is an interesting
lineup in that
you know no abomination no zemo
um yeah it feels like a more good guy
lineup than the kind of anti-hero
suicide squad ass clamp that we often
get depicted in comics that we've been
kind of predicting like these are more
straightforward
good guys can we get the photo up there
oh look at that we've also got of course
john walker
okay there he is
and i'm hard hard pressed to figure out
is that supposed to be val on the far
left there is that who that's supposed
to be or is that sharon carter it could
be sure oh yeah that's hard to tell that
looks like john again
dark hair with the white stripe i think
this looks very the poses look very
suicide squad yeah both what's both
fourth pew's character and red guardian
there well what's interesting is uh them
talking about a world without avengers
that that reads to me actually a little
bit more dark avengers than the their
than the traditional suicide squad type
approach so yeah
they have no direction feige has
confirmed there are no avengers right
now right tony stark was funding the
avengers after the events of uh civil
war yeah and now with him gone there's
no one to sort of like a pay for their
[ __ ] maybe kind of keep everyone
together uh keep everyone well
interesting more exactly brandon bearcon
this shows has been his big theory that
has yet to be debunked he's predicting
that movie when it comes out is not
going to be called thunderbolts it's
going to be called thunderbolts versus
some young avengers mutants something
right and that like it's going to be
about this team
being like because why are they being
assembled it's something they need to
fight and you can't just put one person
against that fight right it needs to be
a team so maybe they're fighting a team
right well and it could be similar to
you know uh this ant-man of the wasp
quantomania thing where kang
is asking scott lang for help we could
just see another villain asking the
thunderbolts for help on something
villain it could be it could be villains
versus villains right yeah true like
they could be assembling yeah like all
the old villains and on the ultimate
stew comic that's kind of what they did
where they had the avengers versus each
then they're they're all their bad guys
teamed up like a legion of doom type
thing and that's why they all fought
maybe the thunderbolts could be taking
on all the old villains of the mcu
coming together some of those names are
referenced abominations emo et cetera
maybe they're that's who a squad of them
is who these people are right right yeah
fighting so uh it sounds like they're
gonna be moving on there's something
else they say thunderbolt starts
shooting early next year
uh we'll see we'll see what's next who
knows yeah no zemo i'm really surprised
about that
i want to put all my money yeah maybe
i could also see zemo being in the film
but not maybe being one of these main
you know seven people that they have in
this promo image you know
it's interesting this is the culmination
this is the end of phase five
thunderbolts right in the middle of 2024
this next 18 months is going to be phase
five
graphics
yeah and this is at the end um
interesting but it is butted up right
next to captain america new world order
well also interesting these are all
phase
mostly phase four characters sure in
this film right no echo with the
exception of bucky right yeah who goes
back to phase one i suppose ghost is a
face yeah which which maybe this is like
a factor of actors can only do so many
things at the same time but like no no
characters from loki no characters from
uh echo no characters from uh the
marvel's right of which that's what
they're moving on to next time
okay
yep great they're flying oh yeah
again
the marvels and
guardians 3 and blade are the other
three films after quantum mania in this
next phase all of which we don't know
very much about
um yet hopefully yeah
uh oh quick we got a couple of super
chats we'll cover here as we wait for
this news to leak in our friend chrissy
and the super chat saying i am living
for elena and bucky maybe this will be
the winter soldier black widow romance
we never got from the comics oh that
okay i love that i like that you know
bucky is um
has been denied a nice romance you know
he was on the apps he was he was trying
to get out there that's right and falcon
winter soldier but never got that he
didn't have his it takes another like
assassin to you know to be able to go
toe-to-toe yeah yeah
uh there'll be some um awkward chats
about reproduction uh between him and
elena
yeah right uh tiana paris uh and and
brie larson and uh our new rockstar's
friend iman fulani are now on stage to
talk about the marvels okay uh we'll get
some more info about that uh coming up
soon i i'm i'm still curious i don't
think they've announced like an
antagonist for that film we think it's
probably having to do with like a cree
scroll war or something similar to that
but uh and maybe we'll learn more about
that after we see secret invasion but
but no real so far just a freaky friday
like uh setup
yeah what if they're setting up like
somebody we haven't seen yet that's
coming down the pipeline kind of like a
kang situation with where they're
setting up someone new from deep space
obviously that's coming through what do
you think it's truly is freaky friday
and brie larson just has to go to high
school
let's do it um though she doesn't look
like uh the miss marvel character so
that would be extra strange
but yeah excited we don't know any
beyond those characters that's really
all we know about that film and it's not
far out it's um
that's the the third movie we're getting
in this next phase next year next year
about this time now mania after
guardians three
july 2023 we're getting to marvel yeah
and and you know
speaking of um guardians of the galaxy
vol 3. james gunn tweeted that he wasn't
going to be at uh a d23 this year he's
working on guardians of the galaxy
volume 3 in the editing room uh we'll
see if they make any announcements about
it or show some footage but i wouldn't
be surprised if uh they kind of keep the
lid shut on that one sure it is the next
movie after quantomania right we're
getting this may of next year uh so less
than 12 months away but like we've been
talking about they're trying it's a
little different story with the d20 or
the disney plus shows that they kind of
want to promote and get excitement about
but these marvel movies kind of sell
themselves oh yeah and it feels like
they're kind of narrowing their
promotional window so that they're not
like talking about these movies for
years but rather just for the window
between the previous movie and the next
movie is when they push it really hard
so we still hope to see some stuff um we
got a a fun look at um the high
evolutionary and
special this this group no it's nexus or
this one
so that might be the first guardians
thing we actually really see because
that's coming uh coming up james gunn
sort of referred to that as the like the
epilogue of phase four so it seems like
he'll maybe still have some phase four
stuff happening rather than kicking off
phase five
yeah yeah maybe there's gonna be a whole
bunch of moments in that where they're
going to be in the middle something be
like where's groot and he's going to be
having all those adventures and
i am grouped that's how they're going to
tie those in
lots of people in the chat speculating
on how zemo might be still be in the
thunderbolts and that's true they might
not have announced all the thunderbolts
maybe he's an antagonist maybe they're
fighting the
zemo maybe somebody speculated i saw
they're trying to break him out of jail
that would be an interesting uh twist or
he's hiding out on the middle of a dance
floor just cut it up and they find him
there he's day 406 into his crazy trip
daniel's role is in that benedict wong
category of he seems game to show up
whenever they call right like he likes
playing that character and he's a fun
fit so maybe it was a scheduling issue
if he's shooting or filming something
else because they have so many a-listers
in all these projects they're gonna have
to have they're gonna have to have
conflicts here and there and maybe he
was one of them because yeah zemo not
being in the thunderbolts so that could
be a big yeah he's gotta be in there
he's gonna pop up sure he's like
walkers
quick recap as we head into the uh deep
into the third hour of our broadcast
here uh we've gotten a lot of news a lot
of trailers a lot of footage um some of
which has been released publicly
anything that hasn't been released
publicly we will uh get on the phone as
soon as the panel's over with our uh
members of our cast that are there live
brandon barrett tommy bechdel and eric
voss and they're gonna recap some stuff
for us anything that we didn't verbally
already recap but we started out with
lucasfilm we got some willow
trailers and then we got uh first
footage from um tales of the jedi an
animated uh six-part series that's going
to be coming out soon it kind of sets up
the ahsoka series which we also got a
little bit about a lot of we got our
first trailer from mandalorian season
three
um we got our first glimpse at uh
skeleton crew the first
uh star wars film since last jedi uh
that's coming up sometimes skywalker
yeah all right skywalkers are yes um uh
great oh yeah no just new news some more
marvel stuff uh nina costa says she's
pitched kevin feige about 17 movies uh
so it's exciting that she's getting her
first stab with the marvels and it
sounds like goose is back
everyone's favorite flurk in this baskin
uh the marbles so we'll see if uh fury
loses another eye yeah
watch your precious items love that
little
a lot of marvel news that we've gotten
through right we got a full trailer for
secret invasion only some of which we
could play before getting our stream
taken down by the copyright overlords uh
but we'll be doing a full breakdown of
that on the new rockstars channel asap
eric boss is probably already doing it
in his mind um we got director confirmed
for fantastic four matt shakman from one
division no other news from fantastic
four um we got a thunderbolts lineup
announced very recently this so we got
ghost red guardian taskmaster which
taskmaster we don't know
bucky
uh elena bilova john walker led by
val uh julia lillary drives his
character i don't know anything else yet
but we know those characters confirmed
for thunderbolts very excited it sounds
like uh folks at the hall were treated
to a little trailer for the marvels and
that's going to be it for marvel's sort
of uh presentation today at d23 so uh
not we got a secret invasion trigger
which was very exciting
uh we got a werewolf by night teaser
that was what was super fun but not a
whole ton in terms of public footage but
a ton of footage was shown to audiences
at d23 so stick around we're gonna be
talking to people that were inside of
the building they would be coming to us
live about what they saw and we can get
some of their opinions on some of this
cool stuff is the panel's still going
panel is still going okay that's it for
marvel so we're thinking again they're
ending big we know they're going to end
big there's a lot of casting
announcements so we're anticipating some
kind of movie stars getting pulled out
there and being like welcome you're new
howard the duck or whatever but no
deadpool no
no deadpool three yet no mutants
announcements um nothing about blade we
just got marvels so again the next phase
quantum mania guardians three nothing
yet nothing yet about guardians 3 or the
guardians holiday special then the
marvels which we just covered a little
bit then blade
series in order secret invasion got a
full trailer for that excited about that
echo we got a little bit about that cast
talking some explanation of what that's
going to look like vincent d'onofrio
came out also set up um daredevil born
again which is not till the following
phase
is phase five that is this phase sorry
later in that phase yes um a little bit
about loki season two uh iron heart in
connection with wakanda forever
obviously riri williams appearing in
both properties ryan coogler directing
and or producing both of those excited
for that still nothing about akatha
house of harkness also confirmation uh
iron wars is happening armor armor
secret wars
lots of wars lots of iron and armor uh
getting thrown around armor wars is
happening kind of hinted at that it is a
bit of a continuation of what's going to
the events taking place in secret
invasion right maybe
lead into another now i will say they've
moved on to 20th century studios uh
james cameron is doing a little video
about uh avatar way of water um some
people in the chat are speculating and i
sort of agree with the speculation we
could get some mutant news you know who
knows maybe they'll bring kevin feige
back out on
20th stage banner previously
uh brandon uh one of our one of our one
of our uh producers here at new york
city's brandon barrick who's at the
panel right now was speculating
yesterday that it would be so fun if a
deadpool movie was about him trying to
go from 20th century studios into marvel
yeah who knows exactly what we'll get
but right now right right now it's
avatar chris cassio in the chat saying i
want to pray sequel announced me too
well yeah at least movie was great
reinvigorated the predator franchise i
wouldn't doubt it that's one of fox's or
formerly fox now 20th century one of
their biggest franchises along with
alien die hard avatar absolutely right
they've also announced that avatar four
has begun filming so after two still not
out uh avatar three in the can they just
had to do post-production on that kate
winslet is just swimming holding her
breath for 10 minutes at a time
i forgot they're doing four and four
movies you know so they're not doing
five they're doing something oh my god
wait somebody slated to
they're going to be doing they're going
to be doing them as plays by the 7th you
get really get the three-dimensional
effect right you're gonna come to your
house you're gonna come to your house
and uh it's gonna be over vr you're
gonna put it on and experience that at
home wow i mean i appreciate the
ambition and if anybody could pull it
off james cameron the dude has not
missed
um very excited for that a couple other
super chats you want to call out kalei
calais however you pronounce your name
uh thank you so much first time donating
thanks so much for hosting this y'all
you're doing the lord's work and it's
been so much fun hanging out it's been
fun hanging out with you
and again we're getting foot we're going
to get footage descriptions from a few
of our friends that are in the panel so
uh stay with us uh we're still waiting
on some announcements from 20th century
studios but as soon as this wraps up
we're going to go to them and get their
takes uh on all the cool stuff that they
got to see with their eyeballs that we
didn't get to see which is a little
unfair yeah ryan
zach and i had passes we were chosen to
be here instead of watching footage in
anaheim but you know i wouldn't i
wouldn't be anywhere else that's all
right yeah i appreciate it thanks for
joining eric and i guys yeah i
appreciate it really appreciate you any
time this is a stellar a team right here
it is
yeah exactly i think we're a minus
ryan wilkinson in the chat saying
surprise fantastic forecasting at the
end well kind of along the same lines is
like deadpool and mutants right
fantastic four another property used to
be owned by 20th century before they
were required so maybe it's part of this
same panel and i will say right like uh
i don't feel
gypped or jaded or anything like that
based on the announcements but but
marvel studios in the past has saved a
something for last right i would be
surprised if disney doesn't want to you
know
put something out there that's going to
create a bunch of headlines right they
want something you can't do the hey matt
ackman's directing fantastic four no
more news on that goodbye without like
having something in the bag because they
know they know what fans want you know
what fans are expecting they're
in terms of studios that are really
tuned in to what the fans want it feels
like marvel studios is like you know the
studio that is like hey we're gonna
we're gonna tell really good stories
we're gonna give fans what they want
with some exceptions but i would be
surprised if this panel doesn't end with
a bang well the the phase six calendar
is so bare and granted we're very far
away but you i thought for sure they
would have been saving stuff not that
far away 2024 starts phase six you know
it's not really i want as far as content
in terms of yeah
you would think that they would be they
would fill that up and not be waiting
for like i don't know a new york comic
con or something like this
[Music]
i feel a little blessed that they've
stopped really showing 3d
uh films in like the imac showings and
they're just doing them in 2d now with
the occasional 3d show yeah but you know
james cameron wants that fancy three
days i liked i liked avatar in 3d that
yeah there's only been a few films that
have done 3d well right some of the
animated films because it's all natural
right they can just export it in 3d and
these films that are actually shot in 3d
like like avatar and some other films
and you know it's like the trailers look
gorgeous you know he's gonna bring some
crazy technology and like could be a
film unlike anything we've ever seen i
love
john what you said a few minutes ago
about headlines now obviously we've
gotten trailers clips things that are
gonna pop
our audience the new rockstars audience
us right we've got enough to speculate
for months about all these projects but
i don't know that there's like
a headline headline new york times front
page kind of thing now they could still
get there right there are some big names
that have been talked about you're
kianos you're denzel's you're even a
hugh jackman coming back right that
moves what has already happened to the
front page of everything right right
right uh yeah yeah that green room is
probably popping right now oh yeah
tingling with excitement
so this is still an amazing d23 with a
lot of really cool things but yeah if
it's still going yeah it's still going
but if if that's what we have for marvel
i i understand the feeling of being a
little bit like oh you know because we
would want that home run moment and yes
so far
you know we've got other than a great
d23 there hasn't been that bobshell
front page thing that you've been
talking about also though i know there's
some people saying they're kind of like
a little disappointed in the chat think
of all that we got today oh my gosh we
got multiple trailers released to the
public never seen before mandalorian
season three secret invasion werewolf by
night right like and then confirmation
of things confirmation of things and
then like clearly a lot of footage shown
in person that will soon be out there in
the public right in in trailers and
other things like that like we're a
little spoiled as a fan base
d23 comic-con have a little bit of a nba
nfl draft
kind of energy well we're always more
excited about the stuff in the future
than we are about the stuff in the
present because it's unlimited potential
right like until the cast is announced
and the cast of fantastic four or
whatever can be anything right we're
most excited then then it gets confirmed
of who it is we're a little less excited
then the movie comes out and we're
enjoyed joyful but you know
it's not the thing that was in our brain
so hey don't beat yourself or marvel up
uh this has already been awesome uh how
lucky we get to be alive right now
because you know being a kid growing up
loving comics i'm sure like most of you
this would only only have been a dream
to get to enjoy some of the stuff let
alone a thunderbolts movie yeah that's
insane and look at how tuned in we all
are yeah we we tuned in we're buzzing
we're refreshing our twitters and
everything yeah like that's part of the
excitement and the fun of all these
marvel and and disney things being
announced yeah yeah and somebody
pointing out in the chat better than dc
fandom
which you may never get
uh the already canceled uh for this year
dc fandom dc
we love you we want you to do better we
want you to yes okay
we're we're ramped up for black adam we
hope that kicks ass uh shazam any other
all the other
aquaman two uh get kevin conroy in the
mix somehow somewhere
yeah he's the voice of batman forever
we need him
i mean the only reason we're talking so
much marvel today is because they're
giving us a lot to talk about but we
want you to do the same thing dc we're
rooting for you we need two big
competitive superhero universes iron
sharpens iron you know that's that's
right exactly yes i'll say this too
right like while i like sit down um
you know
we we got almost everything that i was
sort of expecting right apart from maybe
a fantastic forecast announcement we got
a secret invasion trailer we got a
mandalorian season three trailer like
you know those are the big things that i
was sort of expecting we would get and
i'm so excited they looked super fun oh
yeah don't you also think they've got to
keep something in the can for comic-con
yeah 20 times all the beans you know
what i mean is that that far out and if
they i mean if they announced everything
through 2024 like what else are they
going to talk about yeah we're always
going to be talking about stuff five
years out yeah plus can you imagine a
studio
making this much content
right like this much high level
expensive fancy interconnected content
they've got a lot on their hands now
they're the most like disney is the hit
machine they make all the money right
like they've they've had the best track
record the last like five years really
and like marvel's been a huge part of
that but like
yeah they can't i mean
there's only so much they can do at a
time we've got to be happy for what
we're already doing one thing i was just
thinking too is that with black panther
coming out so soon we might get double
trailers for you know before that movie
so you might be watching ant-man 3
trailer before that and in addition to
other things that you didn't get to see
today because they're saving it for the
theater experience yeah and not to take
anything away from avatar way of water
which i i
you know i think is actually a really
good movie when has james cameron ever
disappointed anyone uh he always comes
out like when we first heard about this
avatar movie everyone was sort of like
what's this weird we first heard about
this movie in 1998
but the dude doesn't really miss i mean
i know like avatar maybe hasn't aged
super well in people's minds and
memories but seeing that movie in the
theater was such a spectacle and i think
we're gonna get that too so uh just to
give people a preview of what they're
showing at d23 for for way of water um
it sounds like uh zoe saldana and
sigourney weaver are both there they
brought out a bunch of younger actors
who's playing the children of the navi
in this movie um and they're doing a lot
of cool you know underwater scenes with
some really interesting new underwater
creatures one of the things that
i loved so much from that movie was the
creature design of both sort of those
flying creatures but also like all the
creatures that were sort of running
through the forest um so it seems like
the scenes that they're showing are not
super related to one another it's not
really a trailer it's sort of a montage
similar to that first trailer that they
showed right um there's this you know
dramatic scene in the lab it seems like
there's a forest scene so we are still
going to be on land in a lot of these
things but i'm really interested to see
what james cameron is able to pull off i
was watching one of those corridor crew
cgi videos that they do all the time and
they were sort of breaking down how
difficult some of the water simulation
stuff that they're doing in this movie
is and if nothing else these avatar
movies are gonna propel filmmaking
forward in some really cool ways and i'm
sure even you know with black panther
wakanda forever coming out with all of
the you know
atlantis stuff although i think it has a
new name they're doing all the water
stuff with that i'm just excited now
that you know i'm sure
the folks at you know ilm or whoever's
doing the visual effects for these
etc are sharing notes um and working on
the same projects and it's just gonna
make filmmaking so much better right
yeah oh yeah and hey now the 20th is
under the the mouse house umbrella you
know maybe james cameron shares some of
these secrets with the uh feinstein
right and like i was thinking that
watching the black panther 2 trailer and
seeing the uh seeing all the you know
the people from not atlantis swimming
through i was getting avatar vibes from
that just from the little trailer so
holding onto that big whale exactly yeah
yeah so in that epic scope of it i'm
sure they have bear trap one two four in
the super chat saying no t michael
directing announcement
he's with mr nasty at the moment dr
nasty there's time time kevin mcdonald's
in the room i don't know how deeply we
got into the trailer description for the
marvels but uh it sounds really fun uh
eric foster is describing it as
incredible kamala carroll monica light
powers entangled captain rambo as an
astronaut at a saber space station with
nick fury maybe that's sort of we saw
the scroll say that you know you're
needed to monica at the end of juan
division and and nick fury was in that
space station at the end of far from
home so
it sounds like it's a saber space
station um
monica touches the light field kamala is
now in a space suit and kind of gives a
wave to nick fury i wonder if she i
wonder if fury is a public figure in the
mcu
um
monica crashes on the moon with some
cree warriors so it sounds like it's
going to be a true action movie right it
sounds like a lot of fun that's awesome
that's great i'm looking forward to it
yeah excited to see that footage too and
see what that looks like yeah kamala
come on meets goose freaks out when the
floor can devour someone
uh sounds like it's gonna be a real romp
the trailer was set to beastie boys
intergalactic
i love that little beastie boys in a
trailer wait a minute
aren't the basic boys famous for not
wanting their music
and they said yes to star trek because
they're big star trek fans maybe they
maybe they saw that check come in and
they were like ah we'll do it after that
yeah uh yeah maybe spike jones got him
on the phone it was like hey guys uh
take this money uh it's interesting that
the that they're on a saber station and
not a sword station that was what we all
thought originally is that uh the
opposite of shield was sword which was
the or the space version the space
version oh which was shown in one
division well and it sounds like zwei
ashton who um she she had that talk
shows way on uh yeah
thank you uh is is the villain of that
movie mysterious not named carrie's a
hammer-headed staff i'm sure
give us a couple of days and we'll have
like six different people that she could
be playing yeah oh interesting yeah yeah
so
that looks pretty fun too
uh okay cool excited to see again those
that you know the captain marvel and the
miss marvel are like incredibly visual
franchises right the way their powers
are manifested look really cool so like
that trailer footage whenever that does
come out will like look awesome too
it'll be interesting to see how these
like very different kind of powers
interact as you pointed out there john
um cool cool cool uh
well-rounded mom in the super chat sand
this has been a great thing to listen to
while running errands you made great
grocery shopping fun uh thank you
well-rounded mom do it for y'all yeah i
would argue grocery shopping is fun no
matter what you're listening to i could
spend days in the produce aisle picking
through the envy or the cosmic crisp
apples um i could talk fuji at my job's
fuji
it's always honeycrisp time
okay cool and so we're again we're in
the middle of the 20th century panel
right now knee deep in avatar footage
and news that movie is coming up
december november this year yeah
later this year avatar two
yeah chris christmas christmas so we'll
be covering that i mean it could be you
know this has been an interesting year
for films we had
uh you know late last year no way home
kind of leading into uh multiverse and
madness earlier this year
door 11 thunder july has been kind of a
long dry period
um with the only kind of top gun
maverick and
grey man come on now okay well i'm
talking theaters i'm talking theaters
eric uh and rise of gru and whatever and
there's been like this is like the last
like month has literally been like the
lowest box office month ever just
because there's no films coming out um
now the movie the year is ending strong
though wakanda forever boom big drop we
got um avatar 2 way of water big both
those movies could end up being the
biggest movies of the year or at least
are going to be just huge spectacles to
get us back into theaters if we haven't
been there in the in a minute um as well
as a lot of fun like interesting more
oscar-y
uh character drama kind of movies coming
out as well that we're excited about
don't worry darling's coming out don't
worry darling is that coming up this
year yeah yeah it is
knives glass onion and knives we'll be
on netflix um and unlimited release
halloween kills yeah is going to be i
think simultaneously released in
theaters and on peacock interesting um
but we're excited about that it's kind
of the end of that current run of
halloween films um there's some good
stuff coming at the end of the year it's
a real bad dry period right now so
there's nothing in the theater but uh
jesus in theater that's okay that's a
fun one
for jesus yeah i had a good time
watching that in the theater when you
were talking about hong kong for jesus i
forgot that that was a movie that came
out and i thought you saw you saw
someone saying hunk for jesus i was like
i don't know what this is related to
but you know and then as we've already
talked about yeah yeah
we'll continue go on
we already talked about next year
i mean so much right in addition to
there's like a mission impossible movie
next year there's a lot of
one of the dc movies right yeah yeah
three dc movies next year four marvel
movies um next year's gonna be a finally
the studios are kind of caught back up
since the pandemic a lot of the movies
that have got delayed because special
effects weren't ready or shooting got
delayed or whatever right through this
low and post pandemic like everything
really hits next year it's going to be
an awesome year and that's not even to
mention like the disney plus series that
are going to be coming at us there's a
strong side of disney plus absolutely
coming out yeah yeah and the joker
musical joker right that's actually that
next year appreciate i do think so um it
might be if they're getting rid of the
film now yeah it could be next year
we're spoiled i mean clear clear out of
the paint joker's coming in you know
what i mean like make way
um yeah there's a lot of good stuff and
that should continue into 2024. good
time to be a movie fan let's all cross
our fingers for no no new pandemics uh
that delay anything or keep us from
going out and enjoying uh movies in
person in theaters with our buds uh
we'll be covering all that stuff of
course here at new rockstars
um and even though it's been a dry ass
period at the movie theater it's been a
pretty good time for streaming right now
we got house of the dragon uh kicking it
on hbo we got rings of power it's weird
uh sister wife uh series on amazon
that's doing fun stuff and then of
course we're in the middle of she-hulk
and andorra's about to start off oh
don't forget rick and morty that new
season just started um we're covering
all that stuff here on new rock stars um
i'm really excited about that shout out
to a couple super chatters new master
saying i could see zach in the pocky
chip aisle
every episode of the break room
henceforth we'll have zach eating a
pocket chip you should have seen you
should have seen the two of them at the
in the break room sink just like heaving
and hawing over some lactose free milk
you can go back and watch tomorrow's
episode do it go back and watch it slash
legend two yeah it says what if deadpool
and the mutants got into the mcu through
the purple rift from no way home they
would have to know the identity of peter
parker if that were the case which is
possible deadpool and peter parker do
have an interesting relationship with a
lot of comic books i love that pitch for
connecting the films of three different
studios right like sony the
fox sony fox and marvel sony wanted to
use that same portal uh flash legend so
yeah
by bringing vulture back exactly yeah i
mean they kind of did with venom at the
the post-credits scene yeah yeah that's
right that's right
so i'm curious from you guys favorite
thing that we got to see today
by night hands down we'll play that was
really damn cool really exciting i i
would say it's like
i haven't decided three way tie up there
the mandalorian season three trailer
looks awesome the werewolf by night
trailer looks so weird and fun
and different from anything we've seen
from this studio i kind of can't wait to
see if they stick the landing on that
and what what what it looks like and
then
yeah that it almost got our stream ended
but that's your good innovation yeah
that first half was legit that's what
i'm most excited about you know when i
first started working here at new
rockstars it was it was sort of after
uh after captain marvel after end game
but we were still in our scroll search
phase so uh you know it was a lot of fun
to do some of those old who the heck is
the scroll
uh
videos and i think like all of the like
mystery and intrigue around that show is
gonna be so fun it's a tone that marvel
hasn't done in a little while now having
like you know who can you trust type
stuff which which is gonna be a blast
and i'm having so much fun with with
she-hulk and the tone of that show but
uh it's gonna be fun to have a total
reversal of tone and go back to secret
invasion which is really taking itself
seriously at least from the looks of it
yeah a little um
a little
uh winter soldier energy
right a little we thought we might get
some of that energy in falcon winter
soldier but that turned into more of
kind of like a a different kind of
actiony more movie than a thriller kind
of spycraft kind of thing but um i know
we're all really really looking forward
to some cast new casting announcements
with fantastic four and whatnot but i
was really excited to see what we did
get to what we did get which was you
know vince de nofrio which was you know
charlie cox going back it's daredevil
some more talk about that learning who
the thunderbolt uh team is going to be
was really fun too red guardian was
never in my mind going to be on the team
so
yeah or bucky or ghost uh well there's
another good one that i heard rumored
but to see her get to come back and then
them kind of building the team with all
these you know ex military x assassin ex
black ops characters yes that's that's
it was fun to kind of finally get a
little bit of direction in the kind of
toys exactly yeah exactly that's a good
point obviously ghost has some kind of
powers from her weird experiences there
she can kind of phase two things but
otherwise this is a pretty street level
red guardian has some equivalent of
super soldier serum but otherwise like
john walker yeah and john walker yeah
but like these are kind of like it's a
very street level team unlike any
version of the avengers we've seen
before right that would also have like
uh you know more super powered creatures
or spidermans yeah john walker and red
guardian are kind of the same in that
regard they're both you know super
soldiers
they both have a chip on their shoulder
towards old captain america
right yeah maybe we'll get to finally
see on film the red guardian shield that
was something that under the toys and
the figures that they teased um and i
think even maybe his the figure he was
holding in the jail cell had it but we i
never got to see him actually wheeled it
is that vibranium is that or maybe like
the there's that carbonadium which in
the comics is the other type of strong
metal that omega red has
that's i think third tier behind
adamantium and vibranium so yeah it'd be
really cool to see what they or the
intro of adamantium or the introverted
started hitting wolverine i mean we're
really close to more well hinting at
wolverine might be a slight stretch
there
so we got the bed with claws bad with
claws
i mean
[Laughter]
and you know a great way to consume that
sustenance in one of these mugs okay yes
this is the shill portion of uh
this uh we have two different versions
of the official break room mug this is
the better version it's called morbid
time and this is the even better version
because it is more fun hey so uh and to
interrupt this mug talk but i'll keep it
next to my face while i do it uh we are
going to be joined by tommy bechtold and
brandon barry yeah
the panel has wrapped up but we wanted
to get you guys like some real meaty
descriptions of some of the things that
they got to experience in the panel
since we all couldn't be there um so
stay tuned for that they're funneling
out of the theater right now trying to
connect to a zoom call with us um and
we'll bring that to you we're probably
returning those 3d glasses
[Applause]
wi-fi is a mad house down there right
now okay so
confirmed no fantastic four announcement
no mutants announced that's okay dry
your tears with thousands of hours of
good content that we will be getting in
the next couple and it's good they don't
again you can't eat pie and cake and
cookies all at the same time you need to
spread that stuff out you know what i
mean we got comic con next year we got
d23 next year when they'll slip that
stuff in there okay um we're we're too
busy loving the stuff they did give us
again we'll get recaps verbally from the
things that were only shown in person
and haven't been released to the public
here shortly from brandon and tommy
they're also trying to grab some new
rockstars fans there on the tarmac uh in
in the hall
uh maybe chat with them up a little bit
there'll be some good stuff on social
media from them as well um
cool uh
great we're working that out together oh
uh theodore harrison super chat saying
will bucky be in captain four it's in
the new world order film all right he's
in the thunderbolts yeah
um where he left off in falcon and the
winter soldier to
the thunderbolts right no and it makes
sense because that comes right before
thunderball it's cap four right so it
makes sense that to me like it's gonna
be kind of a two-parter right yeah it's
like uh we we don't have the avengers
anymore but captain america is sort of
you know with iron man been the face of
the avengers for a long time and you
think like
that is basically gonna be setting up
these avengers films for phase six and
and thunderbolts i imagine are going to
be setting up sort of those characters
for phase six as well and sam and bucky
are you at the end of the show is
friends and so you gotta imagine that
bucky's gonna be back for sure yeah
yeah if you can get something hey maybe
he gets a little brain washy washy again
and what that's the flip over daniel
brewer was trying to or uh zemo was
trying to do it in uh in
civil war with that little red book oh
yeah yeah
so you know
let the man have his completed arc okay
you don't like us to have nice things uh
like a happy fun well-balanced bucky you
you only want darkness um oh also yeah
somebody pointed out in the chat nothing
from agatha house of harkness which
again is coming out next year no casting
no anything like that as far as we know
that has not started filming yet no i
don't even got any word about that any
other casting beyond catherine hahn
returning as agatha i don't think uh
also yeah and then not a lot of phase
six almost nothing phase six mentioned
we did just the director confirmed for
fantastic four but we didn't get any um
any updates on wonder man any updates on
uh the koi series the only sort of like
the only announcement made really was
werewolf by night right the only thing
that we didn't already see on a chart or
whatever which again
armor works it's kind of that cute being
the one don't forget armor boards
forgotten about it or something daddy
cheeto needs more respect than this
and again i think it's it doesn't mean
that they're not working on it or they
haven't already made these castings and
and slated these things i think it we
were a little spoiled at comic-con when
have we ever gotten two phases announced
at once
right so part of this is like them re
pulling it back be like okay we know we
talked a lot about phase six but
actually our next big thing is phase
five we don't want to move beyond that
too fast right i mean the amount of
things that they've talked about or more
than any phases they've you know been
previous comic cons and stuff just the
amount of content in the pipeline here
they do have you know and we we did some
speculating on the break room a couple
weeks ago go find that video of like
what phase six and even phase seven
might look like because marvel has sort
of like put little flags planted little
flags for these release dates of films
going into the future you know there's
been talk about phase seven sort of
being a phase all about the mutants and
talk about how like some of the old fox
contracts sort of locked marvel into
some actors that they may not want to
keep around and maybe that's why we're
getting mutants a little bit later than
we thought so with this sort of
with this sort of day not talking about
mutants i wouldn't be surprised if
there's some truth to those rumors we
may be seeing uh mutants you know a
little bit later down the road yeah
we're only about two years out from now
in terms of all the things that we've
talked about but there's so many other
things coming down and for a lot of
people in the chat talking about world
war hulk
what i've heard is that um the rights
for marvel to make a movie uh
will be back in their hands around 2025
so even that would have to wait till
later uh because they can't make a solo
hulk movie because universal owns the
rights but from my understanding is that
that will expire and be ready for marvel
to use in 2025 and maybe that's when
that could that movie could be announced
let alone come out right it's funny you
think oh the the disney purchase of fox
got went through you know boom we're
getting mute to the next thing but there
are still some of those little like uh
contracts that they have to come yeah
and these huge very expensive movies and
series take a long time to plan right
like even it's wild that there are
things coming out in 2024 that we're not
or 2023 that we're not sure they started
filming yet right like that is as as
wild as these productions are as big and
expensive it's amazing that they can do
them as fast as they can um a lot of
people throwing out werewolf by night
agatha and blade all connected
in the chat yeah i would say we
i would love for werewolf by night to
sort of look and appear as a standalone
thing and then oh it was more important
than you thought it would be oh yeah
yeah yeah well midnight wasn't tied to
anything at least as far as we know
right yeah so
premiered in werewolf by night or the
comic maybe it could be similar in that
sense it's a stand-alone or maybe it's
tied and we will find out watching well
that was like one thing when either john
and tom were just just talking about
stuff like yeah they also have to leave
a little room in these next couple
phases before something really takes off
right if one of these disney plus series
is like a wild hit like one division
i think was a bigger hit than anybody
anticipated
and so it's like well if you already
have your next five years planned out
and there's no wiggle room to squeeze in
another wanda project right or whatever
turtles was a huge hit uh at least we
need our fast spin right
we would have been seen at least in the
turtles too or something that they need
about this in her own show
it's coming it is coming the fans are
gonna demand it
she's the next sorcerer supreme you
heard it here
mrs sorcerer supreme uh if you're just
tuning in uh the marvel panel the 20th
century fox panel and the the lucasfilm
panel have wrapped but stick around and
hang out with us for a little while uh
brandon barrick tommy bechtold eric vos
coy jondro they're all trying to make
their way out of hall 23 uh over in
anaheim so that they can come talk to us
we've got the zoom window open so as
soon as they jump in that call we're
going to be chatting with them about
exactly what they saw
exactly what they saw in those panels
if again if you missed some of the news
we got trailers for
we got trailers for mandalorian season
three everybody's leaving me we've got
trailers for mandalorian season three we
got a trailer for secret invasion we got
a trailer for werewolf by night we got a
trailer for remind me of the jedi uh
tales of the jedi it's a new six-part
animated show from dave filoni and then
we got footage for uh
exclusive footage at hall 23 that we're
gonna be talking about here in a minute
uh indiana jones five we're gonna talk
about uh ahsoka we're gonna be talking
about
i've had three ant-man and the wasp
quantomania we're to be talking about
the marvels uh there's a whole bunch we
talk about the second half of that
secret invasion on the second half if
you weren't here before we had to stop
because we were about to get flagged by
our uh our favorite uh overlords so all
that is still to come uh i gotta say uh
what a great year it has been so far um
oh oh we got to see uh some some
daredevil uh daredevil she-hulk
conversation we're gonna talk a little
bit more about that i'm loving she-hulk
so far uh we're we're less than halfway
through that show which feels like such
a blessing all these short six episode
series yeah i wanted more from almost
almost all of them oh yeah every every
week the show ends i'm like oh geez i
wanted to watch some more but we got
nine ups with this yeah with this with
it being a half an hour show yeah so and
i love marvel is really expanding they
it seems like they were really stuck on
the six episode thing one division being
the exclusion but some of those episodes
really short yeah now we're getting nine
episodes of she-hulk we're gonna get uh
12 episodes of the first season of andor
well they've already committed to 24 for
and yeah we're going to get 18 episodes
of daredevil so uh
i'm excited that they're sort of sitting
there and saying like hey
we actually we think this story needs a
little bit more time and a little bit
more room to breathe some of these
disney plus shows have felt like they
took their time in the beginning and
they sort of had to rush to get to the
yes i'm hoping with these like more
expanded shows uh they're going to be
able to tell the story in a way that
they want to with with a little bit of
extra time yeah one of the things that i
was talking about on a previous break
from episode is with with uh with
daredevil and and i hope with she-hulk
coming up that they have more
more uh more of about like the court
case of the week and more about them
being lawyers and more about them
telling those stories and with more
episodes you can do it yeah okay so
brandon and tommy we've got them on a
zoom call uh let's see if we can hear
them now hey
oh dude hello hold up no john are you
there i can't hear that yeah sorry guys
can't hear you yet but i see you a
little great
i am unmuted all right we're trying to
see if we can get them uh get them
looped in i don't know if you guys at
home can hear them but we can't uh hear
them right now so uh you can oh i see i
saw brandon you can hear okay great
i don't know i didn't learn asl for echo
so i'm sorry i wish we could uh do this
otherwise
but uh tom john they're calling it the
irishman of panels there people here
commenting
three hour plus time span
this is this definitely feels like the
irishman yes we hear we hear you now
tommy how's it going guys how you doing
we're hungry we're we're fun
we're horny's
well hopefully it'll be morbid time and
then you can take care of that yeah hey
tommy um somebody tried to drink out of
one of your mug designs and their mouth
uh melted
[Laughter]
what oh
wait which witch mug tommy is reaching
into his bag of tricks and i think he's
pulling the card you mean
this mug
this mug that kevin feige begged me for
at the panel
who came off the stage and into the
audience he said i don't want to live
another day in the marvel cinematic
universe unless i get this mug we're
going to need to have that source i
don't know about that these are the best
better okay okay so you guys saw a lot
of footage of things that has not been
released to the public let's start from
the top um any
we we've seen the andor footage we saw
the mandalorian season three footage
other star wars stuff that you guys saw
there in person and what was the general
what's that so let me take a look at my
notes
oh well you know not necessarily star
wars related but we did get a big willow
scoop i don't know if you got that oh
what's the scoop
kristen slater joining the cast of
willow
yeah i think i think tommy we have all
the scoops we're looking for footage
description right you guys saw some
footage from indiana jones five is that
right yes oh my god the indiana jones
five footage was incredible it looks
like it's like an
indiana jones clip show yes
but he's having lots of memories of his
youth yeah she looks great the d aging
looks great it's like you're going to
see the indiana jones stunt show yeah
that's pretty incredible how would the
agency
[Laughter]
looking like a proper indiana jones
filmfay town yeah
yeah it looks like they're going to go
through like different adventures yes so
let's move on to marvel a little bit you
guys got to see an exclusive clip or was
it was it trailer for black panther what
kind of forever or both they showed a
clip from black panther what's under
forever and then they then they followed
up with i think the trailer we've
already seen right yeah yeah with a
couple new shots added into it but the
clip was like uh queen ramona like
in front of the council we saw the same
council guy from falcon and winter
soldier they're representing america
uh and they're basically like yo you're
not sharing your vibranium what's up and
they're like we're not sharing anything
with you guys because you're talking
okay because you're trying to take it
yeah and we see a scene where
we see a scene where like a military
group tries to break in to a place in
bali uh the door milage stop them get
some awesome weaponry yes and then they
bring those same troops in front of the
council and they're like this is why
we're not sharing because you're trying
to take it yeah because you can't play
ball like that and expect us to keep
showing back up to the courts i love
we'll make our own chords out of my
brain i love that little mic drop moment
so that seems presumably to take place
maybe at the beginning of the movie
yeah
yeah it seems like it's pretty fresh
after whatever situation is going to
explain the death of
t'challa
cool cool
um
uh angela bassett in the house was
amazing i mean they have like everyone
here it was it was pretty nice very well
attended by the uh stars of films yes
since and then you guys did get a peek
at iron heart right and you got to see
some of the suits can can you talk about
like yeah in comparison how far along is
she in some of the footage you saw to
you know completing some of this armor
is it very kind of prototypey does it
look more polished
it looked very much like the first
version like yeah it doesn't look like i
know there was that leak of that toy
with like that red smooth armor it
doesn't look like that it looks like the
kind of like put together i'm building
my own iron man
with a box yeah i was going to say in
honor of eric voss a real box of scraps
he trailer yeah
yeah and it was interesting it was
interesting how they described the show
like kevin feige was very much like this
is like magic meets technology yeah like
uh anthony ramo anthony ramos was there
and his character is very much like on
the magic side and she's on the tech
side so how do you have him there and
not make him participate in rogers the
musical they did a live
project absolutely insane and i think
friend of the show uh nico de jesus was
there yeah
oh they got that they got the whole cast
from the show together
i'm sorry they got the whole cast from
the actual show together that wasn't
just nobody except for uh pascal he was
not that bummer he was replacing yes
he was subbed he has understood he was
in understudy with them adam wager
so did you get any waker joke for you
guys
and now did you get any footage of
anthony ramos as the hood or or any
tertiary characters anymore his
character patrick i think
yeah
parker
there's something very uh
generic
but then they did know him donning on oh
like a tunic hood combo yeah
and and was it one of those like hoodies
that like uh boxers wear that don't have
uh sleeves on them absolutely and was it
only really those two characters did you
see anyone else from that show what was
what was the footage like what implies
that the hood has a bit of a crew yeah
yeah you can't really tell who was what
they were supposed and then it seemed
like remy had a little bit of a team too
at the end there they were kind of all
squaring off yeah yeah and she's
definitely at mit uh yeah what's his
name from community yeah
who was it was he and iron man three
yeah
he reprises this role
there she's definitely at mit so they
showed us skyline i thought it was
boston it was really fast it was hard to
tell yeah
well that would be massachusetts you
know
as we all know one of the worst states
in the union in the commonwealth
absolutely
um turn out to empty and coy is here
somewhere so they talked about uh
quantum mania next and it sounds like i
mean neither of you guys were at
comic-con unfortunately but it was it
similar to sort of what
we think we saw at comic-con can you
talk about the the clip that they showed
a little bit
yeah it was like much more of a trailer
yes like scott lang's on top of the
world he's everyone's listening to his
podcast he's totally sold out he's
telling his books yes uh he's living it
up and it basically seems like his
daughter got interested in quantum
technology while he was missing was
working with
uh
him and also grandpa
but like yeah she read all their
journals while they were all gone
basically it seems like she built a
two-way radio that can speak to the
quantum realm and hope van dyne yeah uh
is like originally like what are you
doing turn that off what are you doing
there's only bad people there but they
all get sucked in to the quantum realm i
think that i think what we saw in the
trailer is mostly like the first third
but did i think they like revealed a
more elaborate costume on bill murray in
this one because yeah he just kind of
dressed as like a civilian in the yeah
clearly someone who lives in a city
inside of the quantum realm so like uh
it reminded me of the the the munchkin
though yes yes
did you get to hear who she cassie was
talking to on the radio or like you know
maybe a doom no but the light was like
yeah yeah it was kind of like it is a
radio yeah and then it was like the idea
of you can talk to someone and they can
talk to you yeah so some light came
through and zapped them all and sucked
them in oh interesting maybe and and
that led to kang asking for their their
help or was that disconnected do you
think kang is the problem
in a very funny way kang has a scene
with uh ant-man and this is the scene we
heard about where he's like
where ant-man says he's an avenger he's
like did have i killed your life but
he's saying like he specifically wants a
man because he wants him to steal
something yeah so it's once again scott
lang being forced into doing it going
back to his roots
i've already described the movie as
bananas and like very different than the
first two yeah and like really getting
into it so you said it was really the
mandatory fun mug of ant-man
i don't know
[Applause]
it's a little bit more of like an iron
man 2.
hey uh uh we got a couple other uh
pieces of footage but then they moved on
to loki season two
uh how much mcdonald's signage did you
guys see uh
i mean i didn't see any mcdonald's
signature i didn't see not nearly enough
because i don't recall any of it okay
great what what what we did gene cordero
sighting which yeah
it looks like they're going into like
the history of like the variants like
b15 and eugene cordero's character and
uh ravona rinslayer they're jumping
through time
uh there's like multiple loki's i don't
know if they're variants or like
displaced loki was doing this weird
thing where he's walking down the
hallway and he's like he's being pulled
by yeah yeah someone was saying
someone was saying the tv was kind of
glitching out or something like that yes
yeah it's just glitching out on the tv
yeah you feel like multiple tvs are kind
of like combining into each other
multiple timelines
he prunes the tva and behind the walls
of tva there's all this king imagery
yeah he who remains
and like behind it of like the
timekeepers and behind it you see like
the golden faces of kang like a former
statue so yeah something's definitely
going on there yeah uh backtracking a
lot of the cool more like tva kind of
style
uh morbius uh or mobius mobius was in
like a weird space suit yeah it was very
60s looking like very cool shots i look
like um
luther wears an umbrella academy yeah uh
of course forgive me the actor who
played data and short round in indiana
jones joining the cap oh yeah fresh from
everywhere everything all at once yeah
uh backtracking real quick bear trap 124
says any modoc clips in the ant-man
footage do we see they showed i think
they showed like uh they showed like the
outline of like the tentacle with the
giant head thing
they showed it a couple times one from
far away and the one up close but it
looked like it was like a mask it didn't
look like a modoc space
like it didn't look like it was ken the
king we saw was still just jonathan
major's yes no
yes that's what i was playing yeah okay
and then okay did you guys any glean of
any plot for loki season two any any
kind of guess is where that show could
go
i mean uh tom hiddleston said basically
it picks up where season one left off
yeah that they're like sucked into it
uh he's he's back at the tv and he's
gotta kind of convince them like hey
things are wrong yeah uh
they don't understand that anything is a
miss he's kind of like clueing them in
that they've been basically like matrix
like they're all like in this
variant you know prefabbed over reality
at their tva which is not it's not legit
and then it also seems as though
uh
he's trying like i i couldn't tell at
the end but when all those locals were
around him like did he have his magic
back like is he able to now put all the
fake lookings back up
use a little green yeah yeah definitely
magic and uh tom hiddleston and kevin
feige did say on stage that this very
much plays into yeah that's right that's
what i was trying to think it's very
important yeah yeah how do you think
that'll tie in how do you think that'll
tie in we pulled up a phase five graphic
when when that news broke and it didn't
seem like there were a ton of you know
multiverse shows and movies coming out
after loki season two did you get any
kind of glimpses of of how it might tie
into the multiverse saga like that do
you think they'll be bringing in things
from movies that we've already seen
loki is almost trying to
not prune away the other branches of
this timeline but he's trying to
simplify everything to get everyone on
the same page he he has a line where
he's basically the same there's a war
coming yeah and it's going to destroy
this
place uh and i i think i got that
feeling that ant-man and was quentin
mania is going to set up a lot of this
and it will probably continue whatever
story is being told there
that's right very cool um you guys got
to see some
footage from echo right yes can you talk
me through that a little bit i liked the
footage a lot yeah it reminded me a lot
of prey yeah a lot of the indigenous
actors involved a lot of like jumping
through time there where it's like you
you're you have this history of warrior
in your culture
uh and you're you're gonna be drawing on
that there was a scene where she looked
at her hand and almost like they were
glowing yeah i did i was trying to
figure that out that was very weird yeah
um but yeah it looks like it's gonna be
telling the story of like her ancestry
and like for people and like this kind
of history of warriors
uh and also like kingpin shows up at the
end and he's got a an eye patch on his
left eye he's got one of those weird
like medical ones that just is like skin
color but what'd you get from uh
like that yeah a bowling alley yeah
there was some good action was that
three she was fighting did you get to be
on this show too please maybe a free
sighting
so did it did you get the impression now
that that vincent d'onofrio as kingpin
is going to be more of a cameo role or
do you think he'll be more of a mainstay
in that show i don't know he talked
about hanging some really crazy intense
scenes
a lot of these so they had a lot of
one-on-one scenes together where they
got to like get into all this crazy
like leveled emotional scenes so i'm
wondering
what his involvement is because we know
because immediately after charlie cox
came out he's getting out of that show
alive yeah yeah yeah because he's going
to be involved
yeah yeah very interesting stuff um okay
the next film that they sort of talked
about was the marvels this one to me by
description sounded like the most fun it
sounded like we skipped over secret
invasion and armor wars
secretary
we sort of got to see those things
ourselves okay okay well do they show it
do they show up armored royce hasn't
started filming was there any crazy news
that uh we got out of that that maybe we
haven't already got a logo and
confirmation that they're going to film
it and cheetos and gloves all right
so the marbles the marbles uh uh talking
through some of that footage uh does it
seem like the three of them are all kind
of going to be together from the jump or
are are they going to have to find each
other
i think it was it was really fun footage
yeah it starts on a space station
named sabre which is a an acronym i
could i couldn't catch what you stood
for and that's the dart from home
that's the far from home that's the far
from home space station maybe that no it
looked completely different it looked
very different um and it was uh uh
mick fury was on it i know there's like
the peak space station in the comics i
don't think there's a saber spin station
i don't know anyway it looks like the
peak though it was very long like oh so
you have to see the
i'm sorry you saw the outside of the
space station yeah we did see the
outside of it a very white interior uh
and it looks like there's some weird hex
yeah yeah there's a blue hat yeah
there's like a weird shield and monica
goes up and she's in the spacesuit and
when she touches it she swaps places
with kamala khan is in the space suit
yeah i think it's kind of implied
anytime they use any of their powers the
three of them are linked and they change
things
to each other's body but it's not wonder
why i think it's like they can all three
yeah all drinking swiss spots whenever
they use their powers yeah and we saw
like commerce family like uh uh
photon and nick fury show up at kamala
khan's house which was like kind of
crazy to see right uh
yeah yeah for the tv show that was great
i'm so glad they're back um it's great
but yeah it looked really fun and like
very interesting yeah and there was
definitely still like tension between
monica yeah they definitely marvel but
she makes like a comment about like
changing her diapers and then monica
rambo's
yeah don't call me lieutenant trouble h
background
you called her photon there was some
speculation that she might be photon she
might be spec specter spectrum spectrum
uh did they call her out by name did
they give her superhero a name or or i
didn't hear that i was just kind of
saying both time yeah
well that was her that's her call
signing captain marvel so that that
makes a lot of sense
tommy getting recognized we got some new
rock stars fans on the ground
uh very fun very fun and and then to
round it out you guys got to see some
footage from avatar way of water
uh in 3d
they rush they rush the audience with 3d
glasses they passed them out uh these
very pretty pictures which they sent us
a very pretty photo
and they showed like four or five long
scenes from the movie oh wow the three
the 3d looks pretty good i mean we were
in a big hall not the ideal place to see
it it looks really good the water looks
great uh lots of
fishy animals running around sure is
water in that movie i will tell you guys
water confirmed water confirmed that's a
confirmation for coming back not enough
whale footage for me not enough whales
leaping out of water and flying so i was
a little disgusted by that
but uh
it looks like there's there's two
different tribes of the navy there's the
ones we know the blue ones and then
there's more kind of greenish blue ones
that live near the water they have more
like fin like
uh features their tails are a little
thicker so they can move through the
water a little better brandon and i kind
of identify you with the different
tribes brandon's a little more the water
guy with his fins i mean you know i'm
terrestrial i'm all about the dirt the
leaves spears arrows brandon he's sleek
he moves through the water like a
dolphin uh jake fellaini you uh he's had
kids with with uh zoey yeah he's been
seeing zoe saldana's navi if you know
what i'm saying
uh there's like supernatural weaver's
character had a kid somehow yeah and
then that kid is played by sigourney
weaver yeah
i think it's kind of implied that um
stephen lang's character has a human son
yeah he does the good name spider they
named him spider and he's worried about
becoming a bad guy and i'm like maybe
don't name him
yeah that that to me would be like the
music he's a human son but he has like
the at the navi colorization on it i
thought he maybe that was spore painting
oh my god maybe
yeah i thought he was just appropriating
navi culture which to me makes him the
true villain of the film so
i want to get something from you guys
what was the moment that kind of popped
the hardest in hall 23 what what was
what what sent the audience off off
their edge
i mean as soon as marvel kicked in the
audience i will say the indiana jones
five footage really kind of got people
and then harrison coming out
harrison was like visibly moved yeah
yeah like
uh and promised this was his last one he
said no more and you know as close
personal friend as i hate to mention but
do have to remind people you don't seem
that emotional that often it's usually
pretty gruff
uh massaging your back a little too
rough no getting your head he was moved
to tears he was he got choked up which
was right
dude i think people really pop for the
thunderbolts too yes
finding out that like red guardians
going to be in the thunderbolts finding
out that the winter soldier is going to
be in the thunderbolts
[Music]
who even [ __ ] on himself which was
amazing he referred himself as the book
boring superhero
yeah
oh yeah we did we didn't talk about
kathleen kennedy just absolutely
committing a murder on the armor oh
that's during the uh during the uh a
mandalorian three panels what'd she say
she
she she asked her a question and then
the woman went on to talk about how like
she didn't really speak and she had to
you like you know how to emote while
wearing a helmet and then like kathleen
kenny just kind of cuts her off and goes
like well you've made up for free what
she's saying she's like you've made up
for not speaking or whatever
it got an audible gasp from the audience
like holy [ __ ] i think yeah thunderbolts
was like a a lot of big information
people were really excited by uh the
marvels i think the trailer was really
good for it i was really blown away by
the secret invasion footage that show
looks dark yeah it looks like there's
gonna be a lot of torture yeah uh so uh
it looked it looks pretty heavy here
they reminded i know they've been saying
it but it did remind me a lot of winter
soldier well they got to start making in
america
yeah yeah it looks like they're going to
get like paranoia is going to hit hard
i hate to keep heartbreaking oh sorry
zach will you ask nothing
no oh sorry i hate to keep harping on
this but i'm getting a lot of like
friendly waves from people dressed as
heroes over my mother i did see some
digress this joseph stalin was a with a
with a morbid time mug hey a sale is
a sale is a sale tommy
spelling tendencies
that's funny that's funny that joseph
stalin would be so into uh the
capitalist purchase of a sponsored
you
mug
this is the one thing that could ever
make me a capitalist is buying this mug
that only bad people will buy
[Laughter]
um um very exciting stuff uh before we
go i want to ask you guys
and maybe we can have some other
panelists ask questions to you what what
trailer or footage or or whatever are
you most excited for the rest of us to
see right a lot of that stuff was
exclusive uh
what's gonna get people going the most
uh as a big uh ant-man stan i really
liked the quantum mania trailer i
thought it was good and i thought it
really showed john like the jonathan
majors in it that kang is not your
remains it's very different yeah i think
that i think that movie's gonna be
really cool yeah i do too i think i
think it's sneakily
because you know it's a third ant-man
movie but i think it's sneakily a like
linchpin marvel film yeah but it's one
of those ones where we'll touch back on
it like captain america first avenger
right you know where we're like oh this
is one of the more important ones for
for people to watch and really pay
attention to you know i i think i i have
to agree with that i don't know just for
personal taste even though it's not
something we necessarily go nuts about
on break room the
you could just kind of believe the
authenticity of the creatives around
james mangold when they said that he had
perfectly stepped into steven
spielberg's shoes to direct this indiana
jones fight almost implying like he even
is like correcting the mistakes of the
fourth one a little bit and none of it
felt forced like they were trying to get
us excited for it it felt very much like
it looked good yeah inherently but said
like this is a good one yeah he's like
everybody says that movie that's gonna
kick your ass yeah yeah feliz was gonna
kick our ass and i believed him i am
excited to see
this indiana jones trailer hit and it's
coming out next summer
and you know the footage from uh the
footage from ironheart looks really
really interesting because it's like it
really looks like it's just the
beginning of her journey out there like
where she is she's she's obviously like
they show her having this great aptitude
for technology but they don't show her
assembling the suit in a way that would
be like oh that's the finished product
and even she says i forget like she's
going to try and make something better
yeah she's trying to make it better than
tony made it basically yeah
very cool any other questions for these
guys uh that's great i mean you know
some people are we had a lot of uh big
expectations for this and like you know
a lot of potential uh new announcements
and things like that
uh though we're thrilled with what we
got anything that you're like a little
disappointed we didn't get
well i think the reality is you know
there's gonna be another d23 before a
lot of even some of these projects are
out so it's like
you know
having matt shackman stand up and take a
bow and be confirmed he wasn't even on
stage no sitting in the audience and i'm
sure he would have been like he's over
there i'm sure he was thrilled to be
identified where he was sitting in the
crowd i'm sure that no one came up to
him and bothered him after but uh you
know as another close personal friend of
mine i felt for him but i think like
you know
we
that was a three-hour panel that was an
hour and a half pretty much each of star
wars and and marvel chock full of things
and we have to remember
so much time for me the big
disappointment was not getting firm
dates on some of these shows i wanted
selfishly
to know when is when is secret invasion
let us know baby i got to plan my
vacations around this you know what i'm
saying
these these after shows don't cook
themselves the break room ain't going to
turn the cameras on themselves they need
the straw baby where the straws stir
that drink so give us dates and stir
your drink inside your
mandatory fun mug
in time mugs are very breakable
sometimes even just holding them they'll
shatter in your hand and they're very
sharp
they're very sharp and they feed on your
on your on your medicine
did they have you guys seen the werewolf
by night trailer did they drop that yeah
yeah yes
that was like one of the most insane
things i've seen it was just so such a
hard right turn like it's so like and
they keep referring to it as like a
special presentation like they're like
this doesn't die
like maybe it does or maybe that's the
big reveal yeah but it looks amazing the
girl from the nevers is incredible
that's in it like uh obviously gal
garcia bernal yeah it looks so different
and weird was there very bizarre i agree
was there any hint at like what that
special presentation might mean are we
getting more of these special
presentations
yeah they said they just wanted to do
something fun like the old like tv
specials of the 70s and eighties so
actually the director wants to say
michael chiappa or such a good guy
uh
don't edit that out we're live uh he
actually composed that score for this
this marvel special presentation yeah
and i have a feeling they'll play it
before the holiday special i think so
too and i have a feeling that the way
this trailer was received i bet you [ __ ]
you already clocked in his head and he's
like three more of these next year yeah
oh cool yeah he also feels like he's
going to live separately i think he was
with no blade information that to me was
like no i think now i'm kind of like now
that we can kind of step back from it
and decompress i'm like no blade tie-ins
to anything i could see members of the
press pre-writing their scarlet witch
solo movie articles that they do not get
to post yeah yeah yeah
yeah no no big surprise announcement
yeah and he totally totally misdirected
because he said we also had another
streaming show called juan division and
everybody went nuts and it was like
nothing that was i think that was a
leader that was leading to
that's right that's right
yeah very cool bunch of teams very cool
very cool uh any any other questions
that's great what's your uh what's your
energy level what's your uh thirst level
hunger uh
i'm so hungry tommy tommy was a real
mensch picked me up drove straight here
uh
navigated security lines waited in
waiting areas we we got to eat i gave we
both have had a liquid iv we gotta eat
we're high beats
to say to the people who watched the
break room yesterday you saw that in the
beginning of the show i was in shambles
because of going to the bills game on
thursday by the end of the show i was in
shambles because of a hot one chip that
zach and i lady in the [ __ ]
i will say this an hour after that i
think my body totally reset
and i became normal like it restored my
body to homeostasis i woke up at 5 30
this morning with the energy of an 18
year old and the erection of an ache
hey well thank you guys so much uh uh uh
brandon
i just said that to a lobby full of
people
in turn there you guys have been live
for hours yeah yeah we're getting a
little peckish as well
you guys want us to pick you up anything
any funkos how about uh how about a
party stuff
from my mom
stop by the sonic down there in
huntington
how about some sliders hot dogs yes
both tommy and brandon are going to be
doing some coverage of d23 throughout
the day so uh
head over to twitter and subscribe to
new rocks or follow new rockstars on
twitter uh we're gonna be posting some
cool stuff there uh eric voss is going
to be doing some cool reactions to some
of this footage uh oh yeah we saw eric
by the way you saw eric he he ran off to
his hotel room to go uh he would break
down as soon as the lights came out he
scurried off like a little church mouse
i think he stole his 3d glasses too
don't tell jason
uh so you stick around the channel if
you aren't subscribed already go ahead
and hit the subscribe button we're going
to do more cool content breaking down
some of the footage that's been released
eric has his notes uh for for the
footage that wasn't released and he's
going gonna do recaps of all that stuff
too uh and we're gonna try to match some
of the footage that we didn't get to see
just some comic footage um it's gonna be
really cool it's gonna be exciting week
uh of content for us thank you guys so
much yeah for joining us today on the
break room uh a shout out to tommy and
brandon for being there in the room uh
we're we're here live every weekday at 3
p.m so if you enjoyed some of this we we
tend to have a little bit more fun on
our regular episodes some of it
mandatory uh check out um some of our
great merch at new york's merch.com and
subscribe right now if you're watching
this and you're not subscribed subscribe
to the channel so you'll get reminders
of like when we go live specifically but
also all the great content we put out on
new rockstars including breakdowns of
all the disney plus and the hbo and the
films and the anything that you care
about we're we're doing cool content one
day we're going to be coming out like a
couple thoroughbreds with hot takes and
cool shakes baby i love that i love that
thank you guys so much we'll see you
guys on monday uh have a great rest of
your weekend we'll see you later bye
guys
[Music]